well well well i am super fired up for
today's new youtube strategies i'm going
to be doing some q a but i want to kick
it off with what i believe to be the
best and most effective
youtube strategy and really social media
strategy for 2022 and um it starts with
the big idea of creating a piece of
content that you can create once but
then use over and over again across
social media platforms and so tip number
one in smash like if you're fired up to
be here today
is um i really believe that you should
consider starting a video podcast and so
uh what do i mean i mean that um you
start a podcast that you could shoot
doesn't have to be in person the cool
thing is that you could start a video
podcast um on zoom you know record
interviews with somebody with riverside
or things like that to
create content you also don't have to
have guests in this episode i had pat
flynn as a guest but you can do solo
rounds
um our video podcast is co-hosted
hosted by heather taurus and a lot of
times i'll do like a solo round and
she's the host but here's the big idea
is create a video podcast that's not a
new concept
but let me show you how powerful this
can be by the way
from starting a podcast it's also not
just the fact that you can publish the
video content on youtube but don't
underestimate audio we're at 700 000
downloads across um
you know spotify apple all those
different platforms
so you sit down you record video but
you're also recording audio that's
pretty powerful you can grow on youtube
but you can also
spread it across apple google spotify
but watch
now you have let's say one video podcast
a week
what you can do is you could cut a clip
out of that video podcast like this one
and this particular uh clip here is
posted on
uh
instagram reels and notice like there
was some embedded text at the bottom it
kind of looks nice doesn't look great
it's i mean it's really nothing fancy
about this clip it's
me teaching from an ipad that you can
see there talking into the mic and
delivering some content
um and
and it's uh you know pretty basic and it
was just one moment of again a full
length video podcast but here's the
thing
this clip has 19 000 views
so
you've got the video podcast uploaded to
youtube you've got the audio files that
are uploaded across platforms and of
course those are getting traffic and
views as well but then you can take a
clip from it and turn it into an
instagram reel but then watch this that
same clip is posted over here on tick
tock 62 000 views
and this one's been shared 480 times
it's got 339 comments
4925 likes
same clip posted over on
tick tock right all from one video
podcast but then we can bring this full
circle because you're like sean i
thought this was youtube strategies for
2022. hold your horses friend it is
we started on youtube with a video
podcast and now we've come full circle
back to youtube with a youtube short now
this particular youtube short is
actually somewhat underperforming in my
analytics here but i ain't mad about it
you know we still have eight subscribers
we've made two dollars and 32 cents in
ad revenue that's from desktop viewers
because shorts don't really pay you
unless they're viewed on a desktop but
notice this
even though this particular video was
published back in april 16th about 14
days ago it um has 206 views in the last
two days but even in the last
60 minutes this video has six views from
the shorts
feed and this particular youtube short
is the same
clip
from instagram reels from tiktok from
uh the video podcast itself so
the the big idea today when i think
about 2022 youtube strategies
is that you want to be working smarter
and not harder i mean there's a lot of
work you got to put in but it's asking
how can i create one piece of content
and maximize it in multiple
ways and when you add up all the views
the fact that this video continues to
get views by the way see it
underperformed at first but
um a lot of times the lifespan of a
short won't be seen for three four five
weeks and sometimes they can grow blow
up later and so how hard was this to do
not hard right
once you've done the heavy lifting of
creating a good video podcast episode i
mean that's that's its own challenge but
now you can cut clips out of this and
you know by the way this particular
episode i got a viral tick tock out of
this thing one of these one of the stats
i shared during this talk got like 770
000 views on tick tock it's pretty crazy
um and so um you know and you might say
well i'm just starting well first of all
tick tock's rewarding a lot of people
who are just starting but second of all
um what if you just got 10 of those
results how much awareness for your
business for your brand for growth and
when you create an asset like that then
you think about the power
of posting it as a youtube short as a
real as a tick tock and just to show you
look at this this clip here's again
this is about youtube but why not create
smart strategic content on youtube that
you can distribute for reach across
multiple platforms did you know facebook
has reels so why not post them there too
and so this guy right here that's 782
000 views
out of a video podcast which was
actually some repurposed content of me
doing a little leadership talk with the
think media team 85 000
likes and so if you're fired up uh smash
like and loving this content
and i actually want to answer your
questions
shout me out where you're watching from
today on a rare saturday afternoon live
stream hit the like button and today's
episode is actually brought to you by
grow with videolive.com by the way it is
april 30th at the time of going live and
recording this may 1st tomorrow the
prices are going up on tickets so if you
haven't got your tickets
yet for growth video live um what are
you waiting for it's going to be amazing
and with that i'm going to get into your
questions for this episode of the grow
with video live show
[Music]
welcome back to the growth video live
show my name is sean cannell rhymes with
youtube channel and i am fired up today
to uh hang out and answer some questions
we got england in the house we got nyc
in the house creator people already
planning on being at growth video live
uh
2022 by the way 23 days from the time of
recording we're gonna be live in las
vegas
virtual as well gary vaynerchuk
patrick that david vanessa lau chalene
johnson jasmine starr
uh other people
are going to be there like anthony
o'neil like john bure
um and people like alex hermosie and
layla hermosi growthvideolive.com
because you are a part of the growth
video live show
you can get five percent off using the
promo code on screen if you have a
question post
five question marks before and after
your question so i can see it i see west
virginia in the house kentucky in the
house god bless trey thank you so much
for being here hello
uh chicaless
uh good to see you welcome welcome we've
got england in the house we've got
palm beach florida in the house
caffeine and consoles says i love it man
i saw your talk with pat and applied the
strats and it worked creating for brows
is a real thing yeah the pat episode of
the think media podcast
was a fire episode pat flynn is gonna be
at grow a video live 2022. i'm starring
your questions i'm getting ready for
some questions if you know the rules um
it's about putting question marks before
and after your question so i can make
sure to get to it um and uh super fired
up to answer
some of your questions so here we go
can i convert an in-person ticket to an
online ticket um
i believe that you can
uh what you want to do if you ever have
any questions
just go to talk with think
dot com
and uh let me let me put this up here
www.talk
with think
talk with think.com and we could always
help you out i mean
uh we could uh talk with think.com yeah
that's that's the way to do it right
there appreciate you caffeine and
consoles you have a new name you change
the name of your channel which is cool
talkwiththink.com probably monday you
schedule a call sometime at the
beginning of next week we'd love to jump
on with you and help you out if you want
to convert a ticket upgrade a ticket you
can upgrade from
virtual to in person if you want to
include lunches you can upgrade to vip
composting is short right after posting
the main video hurt your video's
performance
it's a good question you know really
videos are
judged on youtube
each video is its own kind of has its
own merit it's judged on its own
click-through rate its own average
mutation its own watch time
however if you upload too many videos
there's
the theory that you could crowd
home page placement
um you know people who really study the
youtube algorithm like my friend matt
guilin
he said that if you were going to post
one of hi he believes the ideal cadence
for youtube is three videos a week if
they can be quality with 48 hours in
between so that you never have your
videos compete with your other videos
saying that you know we post seven
videos a week on think media one a day
five videos a week
and five normal videos and two shorts
we avoid doing two in the same day
um so i wouldn't do it as a strategy
we have a new executive producer at
thank billy and we were talking and like
you got to know the rules but you also
got to know when to break them and so
like one day i wanted to do a live in
the same day that we had an upload and
we also wanted to do a short like if you
want to if you have like lots to upload
do it
but i wouldn't make it a practice of
posting a short right after the main
video and when possible try to spread
the content out a little bit maybe
maybe uh upload in the morning maybe one
in the evening
i've been trying to make connections in
the youtube scene i i know you remember
me on twitter what's the best way to do
that it's a good question
um you know i got some great
uh thoughts for you
obviously there's challenges like
uh i'm starting a bunch of questions for
y'all really quick so i can have them
here saved
um
events facebook groups
um
twitter groups discords
um
and being they're memorable
you know i see also like this is a
couple thoughts like this is a a logo
like i might recognize your name
but
but uh if possible and i mean i don't
know if you're in gaming it's what it
looks like
having a profile pics and being
recognizable
so step number one if you kind of want
to make connections be recognizable
so get a good head shot with good lit
lighting
and get some good eye contact like you'd
actually walk up to somebody face by to
face to face
at a cocktail party nice to meet you i'm
sean cannell make a meaningful
connection
look them in the eye and connect with
them now
i think there's a whole niche like if
you have a pictures like your nft or a
picture is a gamer icon or a picture of
your brand logo that's fine but faces
are i think can be more memorable and
potentially more meaningful
then once you have that set up
you leaving meaningful comments
meaningful engagement on the people you
want to connect with on twitter on
instagram across the board that matters
so digitally that's what i would do
like i would think about optimizing my
social media profiles and then engaging
in a meaningful way not a salesy way
with the people that i want to connect
with
it's smart to have what's called a dream
50 list
and that's like who are the 50 people
you actually want to connect with put
them all on um a google sheet
you know so you can store it on the
cloud and and and
periodically reconnect with them
um and that's a powerful thing to to do
um but
you know the best way i think to do it
is
uh to go to events like there's no doubt
about it where my career is today and i
understand there could be limitations to
this but like i've been to
vidcon uh six times i've been to vid
summit
all of them i think um i've been to
you know growth video live we're on year
five right now but also traffic and
conversion summit social media marketing
world like
it's i know it's like well it's like
easy for you to it was not easy for me
to say like i was intentional about i
was going to events when i was a
videographer i would volunteer at events
you know you got to get in the room like
one of the best ways in a social media
world that lives online is to make
meaningful connections offline meetups
events
conferences
a lot of times i've found that people i
want to connect with it's almost
impossible to connect with them online
because it's too noisy but as soon as i
could be face to face with them
um
then all of a sudden there's a little
bit of depth context and then our our
relationship online is extended so those
are a few tips i hope that helps really
appreciate the comment and
you know speaking of with which that's a
that's one of the big
um points of our event growth video live
right it's gonna be a lot of powerful
networking there and um you know as a
reminder ticket prices go up tomorrow
may 1st so if you still want to get
early bird i highly recommend
grabbing tickets if you didn't know
we're doing an event in 23 days in las
vegas and a lot online called growth
video live check out this video for
details this thing is your gateway to
get out of the thing that you complain
about but people would rather complain
about how it is than put in the work we
need to start understanding how big this
opportunity is because for everybody in
this room he will sit back in 20 30
years and regret if you didn't execute
in this era it has never been a better
time in the human race ever to actually
just go all in on you
regardless of what you're trying to
accomplish you've got to tell the world
about it this is now the world you're
not betting on this you're finished
[Music]
this is your golden era right now
there's never been a better time to be
here
this is the greatest golden era of not
only business but life
i desperately want you to win
but this is on you
may 23rd and 24th in las vegas grow with
video live by the way uh right now
ticket prices are at the lowest they're
going to be and you can save an
additional five percent off using the
code gwvl show uh when you check out at
growwithvideolive.com
um it's happening may 22nd 23rd on 24th
may 22nd sunday night going into it you
can see all the details on the website
there is a third day it's a business
mastermind day so it's separate from the
main event but if you want to be an
intimate group at kind of a higher level
man i'm fired up uh we've got tanner fox
sean holliday sebastian angus ricegum
pace morby matt stefanina matt bontrager
uh josette pamita john brevier andre
jick pat flynn evan carmichael dylan
vanus benji travis aaron on demand omar
alta corey anthony o'neal shaleen
johnson jasmine starr the rose show live
ryan pineda brett knutson emily baker
vanessa lau heather torres sean cannell
patrick bet david alex haley lahore
mosey and gary vaynerchuk what are we
talking about like
this is insane uh and so it's it's uh
crazy to see uh how this events come
together and again i did want to get
this stream in just because like have
you been on the fence you could save the
most by buying the early bird tickets
you know we still have some tickets left
but prices go up literally tomorrow
because it's may 1st welcome to the end
of april friends and so growth
videolive.com is where all the details
are
we're doing q a smash like if you're
grateful um and we are i'll keep
smashing your questions post four or
five question marks before or after your
question if you want to get it in the
queue um is revere there for a general
session or a special session
um it's a it's a general session it's a
leadership session though it's 8 am
on tuesday so the events all day monday
all day tuesday and john revere's
kicking off the day to get our mind
right our heart right our leadership
right um and uh really excited to have
him there for that session all right we
got any advice on the best way to make
videos to push my embroidery business
also watching on youtube from nc
um
okay so
one of the goals i think is a mindset
shift um
the goal would be not to promote your
embroidery business directly the goal
would be to attract your ideal
client
customer by adding legitimate value to
them
and then as a byproduct they discover
your embroidery business if that makes
sense so i would ask who is the perfect
person
for
your embroidery business like what is
what is the business model and then how
can you create content that will attract
that person
sometimes we're a little too on the nose
if you will
about like if you make business
commercials you make videos just about
your business if you don't really add
any real value then you'll never really
grow
the key is to add
real value up front help people get
results in advance the key is to create
content that people really want to watch
to create free content that's so good
that
people should pay for it but they're
grateful because they're getting it for
free
then people will discover your business
or when you point to your business you
can have the most success i hope that
helps
peter says thinking about starting a
channel but
talking about different topics that lead
to something for example we want to talk
about our debt-free or weight loss
journey that lead to our ivf journey
so
uh your story is important
but the viewer you're helping
story is more important here's the
biggest mistake peter people make
there's a really good book on this
called story brand by donald miller
the mistake that everybody watching this
right now is making is you think you're
the hero of the story
now you may not be in america but it's a
very american way of thinking i am the
center of the universe the world orbits
around me no it orbits around the sun
and
what in storybrand what donald miller
helps us understand
is that
um
you actually your viewer
is luke skywalker
and you are yoda you're old you're
wrinkly you're short and you're green
okay
and so
your goal is to help
luke
destroy the death star
so this is a massive shift because a lot
of times especially influencers and
youtube we think it's all about me it's
we think it's me tube
me
me
me too it's my tube do you want to know
about my story now listen your story
matters man
and your story framed to add value to
the viewer where they can place themself
in your story that matters but peter
what i would suggest
is that luke skywalker wants to either
get out of debt
or he wants to lose weight
or he wants to get pregnant you know
right and so
uh your goal is to come alongside
through telling your story
now can
is there exceptions to the rule or is
there vloggers who like
help people lose weight get out of debt
and and get pregnant like sure but but i
think getting clear on your your vision
and who you help
see when you really become obsessed with
the person you're trying to help when
you become obsessed with the viewer and
you make content to help them destroy
the death star and everything changes
and so um highly recommend that book if
you haven't read it too by the way it's
called building a story brand
and that's kind of the big idea
and and 99 of businesses youtubers
creators make the mistake of again
they think they're the hero of the story
when in fact
the businesses that do the best
are
making the viewer the hero
of
the story
i think that's work worth a like smash
on a saturday
um all right thanks for the comments
coming in
um
i like i like what we're seeing here and
let me let me smash
i'm trying to star and get ahead on as
many as i can
uh brandon's coming out for growth video
live brandon can't wait to see you in
person flying all the way in from
florida
uh we got jason that's gonna uh took
took time off work to watch it online by
the way that's a great idea because
um
don't just get the virtual ticket
but get the virtual ticket at
growthvideolive.com and then block the
time to sit down take notes meal prep
get your coffee ready and really get
buckle your seatbelt because it's gonna
be two power packed days you see how
many speakers we have we're bringing the
fire you better be ready
for just getting
blitzed
with
strategies insights mindset training
coaching that's going to give you an
absolute edge not just in the next year
but for the next decade for building
your brand with video
how can you add a lead magnet to your
youtube description
so if you want anything to happen in
your youtube description i highly
recommend that you just put it
in the top three lines
lydia and that's that's the punch line
pretty much i mean you could add it
anywhere but let's uh
let's give it an old look here
to uh omar's recent youtube studio video
so what we have here is a shot of omar's
legs could we see that again that'd be
great omar in in shorts the
the off scene
there it is
uh
and that the uncropped you know hoodie
on the top
short shorts on the bottom you know
all right so
you can see here that this is a brand
deal all right maybe they didn't notice
that but there's a link above the fold
and it's a link to a gvm light which was
imported incorporated into this video
which
is a brand deal
so this clickable link and one thing to
know about a youtube description is that
http or https is necessary you want to
make sure the link is clickable if you
don't put on the http
colon forward slash forward slash the
link is not clickable i know that
sounded pretty geeky but it's not
clickable if you don't do it and that's
it see like that's right up there so the
question is just whatever you want to
happen lydia it's like
is it an affiliate link
is it a link to your website
is it a link to
a brand deal
is it a link to a lead magnet you just
you could put it down there and then do
you give a clear and articulate call to
action in the video that lets people
know uh they could click on that link
and and get something of value uh that's
probably the most important thing
is
is not just putting it there like people
are just gonna discover it by the way
some good copy around it's important
like making it clear
around
maybe some emojis or something can kind
of even spice things up but a verbal
articulation in the video itself
like
i'm flying solo out here so let me see
if i've even optimized the description
here i don't think i have so what is
this one
i mean like this is actually a great
example so notice this video is
uh broken
uh
okay this link is broken grow with
videolive.com
so if you go to the description on this
youtube video at this exact second
um
the link is wrong so i'm going to make
it clickable by coming in here and i'm
going to go
http live
we're here live and we're doing it
together
h
h t t p
forward slash forward slash save so now
if you happen to be watching this on
youtube
um that link to the growth video live
website should be clickable now
and let's test it because you should
always test things to make sure you have
no dead links
boom we're in there we're ready it's
happening so again
um
like i would typically add a lot more to
the description than this
but i'm
i
got ready for this stream like six
minutes before i went live which is kind
of the power of uh of stream yard too i
made the thumbnail on canva
really fast i mean i don't it's i was i
picked out text from them that said
level up i was like that kind of looks
cool and like threw a picture
of one of their templates
named it through some text on there
clicked facebook and youtube
scheduled it for 10 minutes later and
here i am and now we're together
so so in the one call to action which is
not a lead magnet in our case in this
case
it's grow a video live so it's like you
do want to do the same thing what do you
want people to do fill out a survey buy
your book
you know download a lead magnet or a
freemium of some kind
make sure that's that's easily clickable
and findable
and that's it
plaxin84 says i bought the growth video
live package from the 1k but i'm not
sure how to find my ticket
so we've probably already emailed you
but we'll you're good we'll email you
for sure
um just make sure you're getting emails
from us junk mail
spam promotions tab
uh sean cannell something to search in
all those places and information should
be already in your email inbox but
you're golden you're good uh because you
did get a ticket in that bundle so i'm
excited to see you at growth video live
um how to become a local youtuber's
intern
who's the local youtuber and where do
you live
um you know do they even want an intern
that's
there's a it's a mutual relationship you
know you don't exactly
want to dm him and say hey
hey man can i become your intern
hey bro
especially maybe it's a girl
hey
do you need an intern
i i'd love to
i'd love to come over and help you film
videos
so you want to consider like the
social
dynamics
it's going to be a lot easier if that
intern if that creator is looking for
interns like a while back you can always
send us info to i think
workwiththink.com and we did an
internship open door it's kind of closed
now but like we'll do it in the future
um but i mean i think you just fire off
clear emails
i think
there's a whole kind of a dance to it
let me shoot straight with you joshua
um
most of the time and we don't perceive
it this way but most of the time
like taking on an intern for a lot of
creators can actually be more of a
burden than a blessing
uh if you come if you come in you're
like hey can i come like get access to
everything you're doing learn everything
from you and have you like teach me a
bunch of stuff and not necessarily help
you go further faster so that's
like i think that's why a lot of
creators hesitate from it on the flip
side if you were to
say do this if you were to say
take
a youtube creator's videos and download
one of them chop it up
into
a sick vertical video and be like hey
here's a video i made for you um
and let me know if you want to use it go
ahead if you want to post it on your
youtube short tic talk or whatever and
it's good you know and then you just go
listen i really appreciate what you're
doing and if you want more help um i'm
not like looking for you to like start a
school for me i would love to just kind
of add value to what you're doing and
maybe it could lead to something maybe
not but let me know so really think
about how you can understand their
perspective they're busy their time is
valuable um they don't want to do a lot
of thinking or heavy lifting
and if you do that for them and you
pitch the value of really what's in it
for them i think the assumption is like
i'm a gift to the world i will you know
my presence will be a blessing it's like
maybe but a lot of times it could be
honestly
there's logistics like if a creator
doesn't have an internship program like
you know they don't really know what
they're going to do so if you're
literally like also just be on call i
don't ex i know i don't really expect
anything but maybe once in every once in
a while
i would love to come help or or whatever
um
that's those are some different thoughts
and and your best case bet is actually
finding someone because when we do work
with thick.com too we have like a kind
of an application process so there's
some clarity around it you know are you
you don't even have to be local for us
it's like
what do you want to do do you want to
cut you could how to be a part of some
of our staff meetings do you bring some
video editing to the table do you want
to be an assistant of some kind what is
your skill set
we have you submit a video so i would
look for creators who are actually have
like an open door to an
internship that's probably your best bet
i have a question how often should you
upload youtube shorts doesn't matter
david
whenever you want
how often should you upload videos i
just don't care anymore
said with love and respect
i've been getting this question sean
should i upload
one video a week or two videos a week
yes
you should
yeah but should i upload a youtube short
how many
all of them
yeah but like when
all the time
i mean why haven't you
why don't you post a youtube short maybe
you already have david
like
uh
it i don't know um
as many as you can are they good
why not keep them coming
uh i'm i'm going to your channel now to
look and to see
you uh
and david i'm gonna kind of call you out
man because you're here in love but
you're here for coaching and you ask me
a question david you haven't uploaded a
video
in over a year
okay and so here's here's the thing man
upload videos and
like i'm gonna use this opportunity
david to just like really speak directly
to you and again i hope you understand i
care about you
because i i want you to win period
i want you to succeed
and here's a secret though
you will not be able to succeed on
youtube
if you don't upload videos on youtube
and everyone in the chat said hey ben
and everyone else was like his advice
was too simple not really dude your last
upload was a year ago
so
you're on this stream and i'm grateful
you're here
but
i think there's a deeper question
underneath the question
like
why are you here learning but not taking
action
like i'm grateful you're here but i'd
actually rather you stop following me
and start posting videos
like
all i think strategy matters we teach it
all the time having a solid plan matters
great
having a content cadet cadence we are
highly strategic about our cadence of
when we upload and how often we should
upload but your question is how often
should you upload youtube shorts
yes
is the answer
um
today
and tomorrow
and the next day now they should be
quality
and so that's honestly the only
threshold you know we're seven a week on
think media
but we also have nolan and omar
and heather
and sean and then we have steph and kyle
helping edit we have billy helping us
so we have a high bar for quality so our
volumes increased our quality stays the
same in the long tail we get an average
of 80 000 views every video and now
we're up loading two shorts on the
weekend and we're trying to think about
what the quality is of those as well
but
i want you and david i'm channeling this
this energy past you towards everybody
watching this
stop
pondering
stop asking 50 questions and
overthinking every single move you're
making
and start just posting videos on youtube
like you can't steer a parked car
and the cool thing is david was posting
but he stopped so the key is like you
got to get the car revved up again and
stop worrying about what other people
think and stop like
thinking
asking them well will this be right or
will this be judged or will there be a
hater or will there be a troll like
probably but who cares
your dreams are bigger than the critics
the only way you're ever going to
actually get momentum and success is by
taking massive imperfect action
phrase of the day my friend write it
down drop it in the chat
m
i
a
m i a drop it in drop it
in the chat
what's it stand for
massive
imperfect action that's where the action
is that's where the growth is you just
start taking massive action post in
shorts post a long form video test out a
live stream well what if nobody is on my
live stream go live anyways and pretend
a thousand people are there
don't go don't turn on your live stream
and go
um
oh shoot
oh my gosh i knew this was a bad idea
um okay i'm gonna wait for people to
join
okay um okay so
okay i don't know what i'm talking about
today but
let's wait until people join okay um
shoot
oh yes someone's here oh they already
left okay uh no don't do that if zero
people are there
hit go live and say
what is up sean here in this video i
want to talk about why advertising fails
doing a book review
do the book review be brief be bright be
fun be done turn it off seven minute
live stream end the recording doesn't
matter if you messed up doesn't matter
if you said um 700 times
just post the video stop worrying about
how many viewers are there stop worrying
about if people are going to judge
your teeth if people are gonna be
critical of the gray in your beard cause
they will but who cares because they're
sitting there on the sidelines
they're whether they're cheering or
jeering you gotta shut out the noise and
focus on posting
content
okay
and so
massive perfect
massive imperfect action
so you're posting videos you're posting
shorts you're posting lives you're doing
it you might post 50 videos 100 videos
200 videos and you're overthinking each
one they're not getting enough foods who
cares you're practicing you're leveling
up you're getting stronger i don't go to
the gym right now and go oh i'm not a i
don't look like arnold schwarzenegger
yet well obviously because i haven't
been doing the work so if you haven't
posted a video in the in a year i know
you haven't been doing the work
and listen i want you to
buy my book you know or or come to grow
a video live but you know what i want
more than that
i want you rather you do the work i'd
rather you not do any of those things
and take the time to do the work
okay
let's hit that thumbs up button if
you're feeling
the energy on a saturday afternoon
it's time to do the work and with love
and respect david i just want to say
it's time for some massive imperfect
action how many shorts yes should you
post a video absolutely should you get
back in it absolutely you're not getting
any judgment from me you're getting
hopefully encouragement for me i'm
trying to add courage to you to just
stop overthinking and start posting
videos again
common sense mamita says
where can i put my lead magnet into my
youtube description hey just answer that
top three lines of text would be the
best check out the replay of this very
video if you want some specific
strategies on that it was a good little
session and thanks so much for being
here um my friends today
uh this episode of the growth video live
show is brought to you can you guess it
by grow a video live that's right um
because you are a viewer of the show you
could get an extra five percent off
early bird pricing as a reminder uh
ticket prices are going up
in um
short a short amount of time ticket
prices go up may 1st which is tomorrow
uh because the whole new month we're in
a 23 day countdown to the event if
you're on the fence you got to come out
here some details about the event do you
want to get in the room with experts
like gary vaynerchuk patrick vette david
vanessa lau pat flynn chalene johnson
and more and would you like to meet
hundreds of other creative entrepreneurs
just like you well then do not miss the
chance to get around creators and
business influencers at growth video
live 2022 conference you can actually
lock in your limited discounted tickets
at
growethvideolive.com or you can click
the link in this post or in the
description now if you want to learn the
best new strategies for getting views on
youtube and the most proven and
profitable ways to grow online then do
not miss this life-changing event you
can join us in person in las vegas or
virtually from around the world secure
your ticket at grossvideolive.com and
take the fast track to dominating the
next decade not just with youtube but
with video go to growthvideolive.com or
click the link in this poster in the
description to secure your limited time
discounted ticket
can't even wait grow a video live 2022.
it's a pretty historic event and i'm not
throwing that around lightly uh i've
never seen this lineup of speakers
before if you haven't heard about alex
hermozy my gosh super cool having that
he agreed to come out
um
100 million offers great book sold 100
000 copies in six months with no
promotion great book patrickbetdavid
valuetainment who are you most excited
to see at growth video live tell me in
the comments um and if you've got a
question post five question marks before
and after your question
because i'm here for you on a saturday
afternoon
uh all right if i was starting from
scratch of youtube on 2022 what would be
your personal strategy
would you do
a brand as think media or a logo or
brand as yourself as sean cannell with
your face joshua i do more
self-awareness
i don't know man what do you want to do
it's maybe the the big question joshua i
got two questions for you and everybody
watching this
what do you want is question number one
seriously friends
take a deep breath let's pause for a
second
i really want to ask you
what do you want
like
why do you want to be on youtube
like why do you want to post content
like really get deep share with me if
you can like
what do you want
do you want
to be famous
do you want
a gold play button
right
do you want your book
do you want to write a book but also use
youtube to market your book
what do you want
like
who do you is there a particular cause
you care about or is there people you
want to help
what do you want and by the way
think really deeply about this question
because
you know i see
i i want to i want to feel good great
i want freedom
great
can we dig a little deeper i mean
everybody wants to feel good
and what i mean by going deeper is is i
think when you say man i really
like
i want money
okay
well
you know that money is the byproduct of
adding value and helping someone
so maybe if you get a little bit deeper
and you say i want to create a youtube
channel that is the most valuable
youtube channel in this particular niche
like your answer to the question of what
do you want
by the way what do you want in terms of
do you want endless fame and money but
at the sacrifice of your family and
peace of mind of course nobody would say
that that's what they want
but i mean it's seriously
because have you really thought through
what do you want
so we're answering the question is if i
was starting in 2022 i would focus first
on getting crystal clear about the end
goal
you know at growth video live this year
we're gonna be talking about our seminar
system the seven hours of of uh youtube
success but you know what's kind of
crazy is i made this framework years ago
and we've been refining it but this is
actually it's seven r's that work for
every social media platform but here's
the first one the first one is reverse
engineer
i mean start with the end in mind
it means start with what you want to
achieve what you want to accomplish
so joshua like it's a hard question to
answer because i don't know what you
want
do you want to be on camera or not do
you want to build a brand or do you want
to build a personal brand
um do you want to work 40 hours a week
on your youtube channel 60 hours a week
on your youtube channel or 20 like let's
even just assume you could do it full
time
what
what do you want changed in the world
like
do you just want money at any cost
because maybe you could just start in
only fans and start taking your clothes
off
right
like
if we literally were saying
i i just want i'll do whatever because i
want well then
most of us would say i probably want to
keep my clothes on and most people
watching are like sean you should keep
your clothes on
fair enough
this is a big question what do you want
like how clear are you on your end goal
or how clear are you on your three-year
goal
how clear are you on what it is you want
because once you're clear i want
i i want to make an impact i do want to
make a great living for my family but i
also want respect in the marketplace do
you want to be respected by your peers
do you want
you know
how clear are you
on how you want to feel
what you want to be doing with your time
what business model you want to be in
what do you want
and then here's my second question
um
what do you have
joshua
so if i was starting from scratch those
are the two questions i'd answer
what do you want and what do you have
so
do you have a good idea
for a brand
do you have a good idea for a channel
what skills do you have what experiences
do you have what talents do you have
what collectibles
do you have
like if you have
done collectible card games
for
20 years then maybe you should start a
pokemon or other niche gaming channel
because what do you literally have
you're like physically i have like this
would be an amazing channel because i'm
i've i obsess over this i study you know
ccgs all day long i got a whole garage
full of stuff like what do you have
like
when i thought about
you know
originally what do i want
i did want to provide for my family
and i wanted to take care of my wife
especially after she almost died in 2009
and i wanted to be able to work from
home because i didn't know what our
future would be but i also wanted to
make a difference with my skill set and
i also knew that there's no success
without service or there's no lasting
success without authentic service and
actually helping people
so then i said what do i have
and i was like well
i've been doing videos since 2003 when
my youth pastor handed me a camera
uh what do i have i took out a loan and
i have a canon 7d
and a tamron
17-50 lens that was a fix 2.8 with the
vibration
control in it
you know what do i have
and so i started to shoot videos related
to media i had been doing social media
for my local church since 2003 which
sounds weird because by the way there
wasn't even social media in
2003 but youtube started in 2005
and and so i i posted a video and you
know even my first think media video was
was all about resources to help you go
further faster in media you know and i
didn't know what i was doing
but what do you want i knew i wanted to
tap into this creator economy thing
nobody was calling it that back then
and then i just thought about what do i
have i had a lap by the way look at this
laptop on the shelf
i thought in my mind that was like a 10
foot by 10 foot led screen like i put
that there for like graphics i thought
that i was like that's our website and i
was like look at it it's cool animates
on its own maybe it's like this tiny
like toshiba 300 laptop that i stood in
line at best buy on black friday all
night long actually my friend rob
okerstrom
held my spot so i was able to get there
at 2 am
wait three more hours get in and get the
toshiba laptop that could barely edit
video
what do you want and what do you have
i had a webcam this is a webcam
you know i had a message in this video i
was like media is gonna probably be big
i've been doing video and some social
media for my church for a while i'm here
to help
so
that's maybe not what you thought was
the answer to the question joshua
because there's what i would do but i
want to spin it on you and everybody
else
if i was starting youtube well yeah
there's 48 strategies i could give you
however
i'd actually rather turn it and say
what's the best strategy for you and
you're going to get closer to an answer
to that question when you think about
what is it you really want
and then what do you have
tools skills
garage space video podcast studio you
could build a friend's house who already
has gear you can use like literally
being it's not about your resources it's
about your resourcefulness and it's
about looking and be like all i got is
three five smooth stones well that's
enough to kill the giant
you know all i got is you know i got
nothing in my house except for these you
know a couple of jars a couple vessels
well that's enough to get some oil so
that you can cook some food
like
what do you have
you know when you start seeing the
possibilities with what's around you i
think your perfect youtube channel
is at the intersection of how you can
serve the world the most and also
self-awareness about what you really
want and what you really have
all right peter is it okay to talk about
different topics that lead to something
for specific we want to talk about a
debt-free journey
yeah you could try it um absolutely i
mean i talk about different topics that
all lead to like youtube secrets so i
could talk watch
video editing get the boys the free
inversions only version i have buy me um
you know
how do you edit video by the way i have
a book
what camera should i buy by the way i
have a book and it's never this i've
never actually even said it that way
like
in fact you rarely even hear about the
book in most videos but nevertheless
this is an overt
illustration
like
how do you get views on youtube here's a
couple tips by the way i have a book
you know how to get subscribers on
youtube here's a couple tips by the way
i have a book
uh you know
what's the best software for thumbnails
here's a canvas tutorial by the way i
have a book
so
you can
um
have different topics that lead to
something specific peter absolutely i
think getting kind of clear on on your
over all vision is uh is is definitely
the goal but it is possible to pull that
off for sure
um good evening could youtube live be a
way forward sure i think you should do
youtube live i think i think that
youtube live is powerful i'm doing it
right now i think that youtube shorts
are powerful i think the youtube
community tab is powerful i think
youtube stories are awesome i think
youtube um full length videos are great
i think three minute youtube videos are
awesome i like five minute youtube
videos you know what else i like
12-minute youtube videos if necessary i
like hour-long youtube videos i like it
all i think that uh i want to encourage
you
try it
don't think about it don't debate about
it just do it do it a couple times and
then here's what i really like
i like testing and studying the results
because
it's not just do everything and be like
oh great it's whether it's working or
not i'm going to keep doing it it's no
no
the
the sixth r
is review you got to become a master at
analytics you got to become a master at
making data driven decisions you got to
become a master at doing this system but
then you got to become a master at then
saying okay should i keep doing youtube
lives
should i keep doing youtube shorts
don't ask me if you should if you
haven't done it 10 or 20 or 30 or 40 or
50 times because we don't have the data
to determine if you should keep doing it
that's why it's probably a good idea to
stop overthinking
and to start posting because the only
time you're going to really get some
good data to review
is after you've done it
10 20 30 40 50 times
and now you can make an accurate
assessment
of how effective the strategy has been
my friends are you having fun today
shout out if you're just joining where
are you uh joining from uh
what is what are you sipping on today
i'm on my second cup of coffee onyx
coffee labs
um
is the sponsor today i'm just kidding
that would be so sick come on onyx
coffee
uh let me let me give you some
information you didn't ask for so
it's my favorite kind of coffee right
now
and
it is amazing now you might think i'm a
little bouge
a little bougie because uh let me show
you one of my favorite ones
let me show you the one i just ordered
two boxes of it
uh-huh
onyx coffee labs
do you have an affiliate program shoot i
should link up an affiliate link
this one right here man the costa rica
las lajos sl28 natural 36 dollars for 10
ounces
dude
people are out here buying
you know rolls royces and bentleys i'm
out here buying costa rica lost lodges
sl28 natural
you know i took a second mortgage out of
my house so i could buy two boxes of
this coffee
this is this is what life's all about so
anyways um
what are you sipping on i'm uh i'm
sipping on some onyx coffee not that one
i ran out of that one i had to order
more
and we're uh
we're
answering your questions
you should try pharmacy coffee something
local to me and lush okay okay
okay can you tweet me that so because
this chat will probably go away ooh a
plus russian sipping coffee in the
northwest everett
washington
uh
neighbors naturals i forgot what's that
place called it's really good coffee
place up there we'll be there up there
in the summer
and uh
narrative narrative coffee and everett
if you ever have a chance check it out
narrative coffee
in everett a plus russian highly
recommend it
kes
cars
san antonio texas sipping on water
cheers we got london fog tea smooth and
relaxing main games thanks for being out
[Music]
all right
so
loving riot energy sparkling tart
cherry watermelon tea so good cheers
loving it northern carolina uh north
carolina northern carolina northern
california
cheers thanks for being here um if you
uh have a question if possible throw
four question marks before and after it
and um
that'll help me see that it's a question
evelyn
for some shorts channels
they're doing two to five a day
uh i think you have to question like we
wouldn't do that on think media because
well there's also a way to turn off the
the box of notify my subscribe
subscribers some people are making the
decision to not notify their subscribers
when they upload shorts to just let the
shorts
uh do their
diligence to like populate in the shorts
feet or not so we're uploading two a
week and only one a day on the weekends
other people are doing multiple a day
you got to ask i think about the deeper
question is what is your strategy
joshua should you make an llc for
content um i'm not a cpa i am not
a um
you know
obviously
i'm not a tax professional
and everything i'm about to say is for
entertainment purposes only
um but
i love this topic and i got some serious
knowledge for you that's all for
entertainment purposes by the way if you
want kind of that next level
and you haven't heard about at our event
growth video live today's stream is
brought to you by growth video live
growth video live platinum
is our next level it's a third day it's
a business mastermind you can even get
five percent off the platinum experience
we're going to be sharing a lot of tax
strategies
if you're further along in your business
you want to set up your business right
um that's definitely something to check
out uh but this i like this stuff
and thanks for the super chat tommy let
me see if i can get to that in a second
but the llc question is this you know
should i start an llc
um
i don't think you need to
personally and that's what my cpa told
me i was making i was making youtube
video making a couple hundred bucks from
adsense and affiliates i was doing
freelance video
and i was probably making
20 grand a year from side hustle why i
had a full-time job and i said hey cpa
pretty good one too should i start an
llc
so that i can get like better tax
benefits
and they're like
you make 100k a year from your side
hustle i was like nah they're like why
do you need to know they go do you think
you're going to get sued or do you think
there's any legal liability of what
you're doing i go nah i go i don't think
you need an llc
did you know that as a sole proprietor
you can start itemizing your taxes and
taking write-offs towards a business
just as a sole proprietor using your ein
number this is here in the us and this
is only entertainment purposes only
please do your own research
but one of the smartest things you could
do
for everybody watching this is start
moving your way through the cash flow
quadrant and i learned this in a book
called rich dad poor dad from robert
kiyosaki
and this is a highly recommended book
and it's the idea that
you want to move from being
let me actually look up the cash flow
quadrant for you
and then we'll land the plane on this
great question
um
so
here's where people kind of are let me
uh let me get a good enough version
of this so it's nice and crispy for you
oh yeah you ready
this is gonna be good friends i know we
were gonna get this
geeky so most of us probably a lot of us
on here are in the e quadrant you're an
employee you have a job a job just over
broke
and the amount of active work determines
your income by the way respect like i
worked i worked at red robin for 10
years okay
um and waiting tables i wore the bird
costume you know
employees uh
it's just it's you're trading time for
money
so then you become self-employed which
is what you should do in addition to
being an employee
you should start a side hustle why
because there's tax benefits so even if
you have double a w-2 income
the reason you want to become
self-employed is because now you can
start taking write-offs without an llc
so did you know you can write off your
home office you can write off
a camera you can write off software you
can write off online courses you can
write off tickets to grow a video live
now
the ir according to the irs here in
america even if you go negative in your
self-employed
job
um your
uh
for a couple years you're allowed to
take losses when you're starting up your
side hustle
and so you basically can zero out your
self-employed income eventually the irs
will deem it as a hobby but i think you
have two or three years and if there's
any cpas here you can let me know what
the date is and of course you always got
to do your due diligence to see what it
is
but
when one of the
big unlocks that i hope it was worth
your time to be on the stream today and
we'll go into the other two quadrants
but is is you should start a youtube
business you probably already have if
you're watching this
you should itemize your taxes and you
should write off cameras and computers
and software and so and subscriptions
and airline tickets and hotels and
travels to conferences this changed my
life back in 2008 so i started thinking
different
and i started to move into the
self-employed
quadrant which is a good progression
then eventually you want to become a
business owner and the cool thing about
youtube is
videos can create passive income from
for you so it says you own a system
now income's working for you not just
when you're trading time for money so
for example you look at somebody like
nolan molt who's on the think media team
and nolan molt is an employee of think
media
and he shows up and he works for money
by the way so do i
like i don't know why people are out
here thinking
i just don't want to work dude work's a
blessing
god created us to work and find joy in
purpose and fulfillment and work so work
is a blessing but you also want to be
working smarter right and so nolan is an
employee but he also has his own youtube
channel and he's ranked videos by the
way those videos work for him because
they it follows a system
and he makes thousands of dollars in
passive income and his income does not
depend on
on active work so you could be a
business owner pay people that work for
you but you also the power of youtube is
videos will work for you and bring you
passive income and then your ultimate
goal is as you generate and save money
you start investing money and your money
starts to work for you in real estate or
in stocks or in mutual funds or in bonds
or in
crypto or in nfts or whatever your
investment profile
is
should you start an llc that was my
answer i don't think you need one and
then watch what i think you sh unless
you have legal liabilities and you want
some protection by the way unless you
have assets to even protect
but a bigger thought you should look
into is starting in s corp and if you
start an s corp in the u.s
and make as little as 40k a year you can
start saving as much as 5 000 in
self-employment taxes
from just starting an s corp and so uh
if i know this we got super geeky but if
you like this kind of stuff and um
uh you know
are
hey can you repost that super chat
question i'm sorry it timed out i'll see
if i can find it if you repost your
question type super chat all caps and uh
i got another super chat to hit up here
in a second but yeah if you like this
kind of stuff by the way this is the
power about of getting around people who
can uh
level you up you know what i mean who
can uh change the way you think who can
um
potentially create an entirely different
path like there's
tons of ways to not just make more money
but to save money
there's really smart things you could do
you don't have to make even a ton of
money to save money on taxes uh which is
just being wise this is all ethical it's
about just getting a financial education
it's about getting a business education
it's about getting a marketing education
and if that's the kind of thing you're
into i highly recommend coming to
growthvideolive.com
which
is not just the thing i'm promoting
today on this stream but specifically
because it's april 30th tickets prices
go up on may 1st so i do want you to get
a ticket before
prices go
up
um if you could redo the
super chat one did i miss the other one
man come on man let me let me i'm going
to find them this way any idea of why
content
while the content of the channel which i
will name
will launch in 2020 it produces mainly
skits and shorts usually go viral
i aim to grow shorts and i'm in vr we
are right well okay so
if you're not gonna name the channel
gina it's really just a matter of you
gotta decide are you gonna be in
entertainment or education
skits are entertainment
even if you learn something they're
entertainment you know some of my
favorite people is trey kennedy i love
trey kennedy he does skits he's a
comedian i think it's knowing what what
you're doing like who are you what do
you do
so
the reason they go viral is probably
because they're funny or they're
entertaining a lot of times education
content doesn't go viral however it can
be incredibly practical for making a
living
uh and things like that a lot of the
times education content doesn't go viral
unless you do
edutainment entertaining education a lot
of science stuff could be made fun if
business could be made interesting so
the variable gina really actually
becomes creativity and content creation
how skilled are you at making content
entertaining even if it is educational
that's what goes viral what grabs
people's attention holds people's
attention and is shareable
[Music]
randy says i thought until you make 30
000 you don't need an llc again it's a
limited liability company and so
you know
i'm not the expert here
i do know a lot though ultimately
it's maybe just different write-offs
different thresholds
but you can take as much 1099 income as
you want randy
um as a sole proprietor so people you
know amazon pays you as 10.99 um like if
you do affiliates youtube pays you as
basically a contractor then the key
is just to keep good records
so if
if i make ten thousand dollars from
amazon this year
in affiliate marketing and twenty
thousand dollars from youtube ad revenue
this year and i have no entity so i make
thirty grand but while i'm working my
other job w-2 income i decide to buy
you know i upgrade my whole i spend 10
000 on gear lenses mics
lights desk like i just just you know
exhibit pimp my ride i just pimp my
studio you know what i mean like the
thing is just decked out then i spend
you know five grand traveling hotels
tickets uh going to a conference then i
spend
um five grand on software
uh vid iq adobe you probably don't even
need that much but just for like rough
numbers you know um
books and maybe some courses or
something and then i spend i write off
my rent or my mortgage for um
i don't think you can write off your
mortgage you
you just have to look at what home
office deductions are but like i use my
loft to film i use this home office to
film i we use this bathroom upstairs
just for business because we have other
bathrooms so we measure all the square
footage in these places we write off a
percentage of our internet i write off
my phone
um i write off uh and the percentage of
my internet just has to be reasonable in
the irs says mind which i'm here right
now using my internet so do we use our
internet to watch better call saul
season six you better believe it um but
we also i use it all day so it's
probably like we write off like 85
percent of our internet fees
so now
if you follow that string of math
anybody like this geeky
stuff or should i let it go um
now the 30k i made from 1099 income
which people usually hate because it's
taxed
hardcore and they're surprised by it
because the irs wants their money
you've you've itemized it all to zero
because all the gear and all the
software and internet and the new iphone
and everything else zeroed out that
income
so you also
you know it's pretty cool if you are
like me and like
you love
you know cameras and you know bought
this canon r6
you know grab this uh
mic that we covered with tape this is a
sennheiser mpe 400
um
you know
bought that
fixed f2
you know r lens and i love to
uh take you know photos of with with the
family i use all the photos for
marketing
this is the next level business thinking
y'all i use them for ads and all kinds
of stuff so we write off trips because
we're creating content on the trips
we're creating marketing content there's
a verifiable you know uh history of of
what we're using it how we're doing it
for we're tracking our time
taxes my friends
business structure my friends have we
gone too deep here we go tommy hit the
like button how do you overcome seasonal
content like snowboarding how do you
rank videos in the southern hemisphere
when it's winter in the summer
that's a great question if you can batch
produce content you know like i follow a
lot of snowboard accounts on um
instagram and i pretty much get hit up
year round because once
once they know i love it and a lot of
that is just you know people hitting
rails doing little park sessions
and and that's just kind of the stuff i
like to watch throughout my day like
it's gonna get a like for me
so
i think you could like for example
imagine this tommy if you only wanted to
upload weekly videos you only need to do
52 videos
if you focus the entire season on making
videos you could theoretically make 52
videos just during the snowboard season
and then schedule upload them throughout
the rest of the year
um you also could create other content
like
how to set up your bindings and like
stuff from you know
your
your shop like your little
assuming you have like a little setup in
your garage you could have you know how
to tune your board how to wax your board
whatever you know what i mean so you
could do that kind of stuff
repurpose content
um and then you could go endless summer
and you could fly around the world as
well which might be the dream too and
i'm i'm joking because you're probably
not at that level
but why not dream big and think okay and
then that's all i'll write off because
if you have a snowboard channel tommy i
don't know we're gonna go so have it
heavy in taxes this is just
entertainment
check with your cpa
but
dude everything you do
is a write-off and snowboarding is
expensive
the mileage to the mountain
the board the bindings the lift tickets
the season pass the meal is a work meal
the day you're filming if you're up
there with gopro film and stuff
and then the trip to japan
to
to film more snowboard content
how we thinking out here y'all getting
value out of this have you heard any of
that kind of stuff before uh what do you
think about uh
what do you think about
uh
yeah snowboarding equipment reviews
that's a good one
um
claire i appreciate you i wonder what
the uh taxes are like in australia i
mean i know canada is similar to ours in
terms of some of the opportunities
um
and so jessica appreciate that you're
getting
value there's a lot you can write off in
the uk that's good to know gaming mom
and friends by the way man
you have a gaming channel so again
eventually you have to be profitable or
else the irs will call it a hobby here
in the u.s meaning
you
actually show profit and are taxed on
the profit eventually
but even the first couple years you can
take a loss and like
if you have a gaming channel and it's a
business this is why you got to think
like a business owner like jzc i'm not a
busi like jay-z said
i'm not a businessman
i am a business
man
right
i'm a business
so things i'm doing me creating content
me being places it could be a write-off
you have a gaming channel which i don't
so me writing off a playstation 5
i don't think that's legitimate i mean
my cpa you know
but if you have a gaming channel
your xbox monthly membership your
playstation monthly membership your
games your controls your gaming chair
your led lighting anything for your
studio anything for
your passion that's why it's it's
amazing that we're living really in the
passion economy
because you can build a business around
your passion
but really as you get more financial
education
you can
scale things up and uh
make money uh save money
and um
and and for real
and so apparently taxes are rude in
australia
you know this is
this is a good one jessica says again
i'm ready to travel and
like just to let you inside of my world
you know
um i flew into california like i
purchased all the stuff my myself but my
ticket because i was going though to an
event
with a business colleague so i wrote off
the plane ticket i wrote off the hotel i
wrote off everything that i purchased
in that trip
um and i went to a business meeting with
you know pedro andeo
uh and it was it was a party um but
while i was there i met with keith
ferrazzi
i you know uh we talked for about an
hour you know took notes on my phone
and so
uh the uber's like
lifestyle flew to california had a great
saturday my family was out of town
um you know went over to clever summit
meals
for work trips
which i'm working all the time you know
you're shaking by the way meals are 100
right off right now since the pandemic
if you're doing business meals um they
upped it from 50 because
they wanted to it's a stimulus for
restaurants and so
anyways
can't wait to be the business i want to
encourage you spanish blueprints
you already are
and what i mean is i started thinking
this way
way before i was even really living this
like you gotta know and start learning
this stuff
even years ahead of becoming it you know
what i mean
and so i want to encourage you you
already are like
it's actually it starts with making a
decision and this might sound a little
esoteric if that's probably the wrong
word
but even in terms of hearing the us what
the irs would say
is soon okay when are you in business
the moment you make a sale
when do you make a sale the moment you
get a dollar in adsense the moment you
get a super chat
one super chat maybe five bucks comes in
the moment you sell an ebook
so when are you in business when you
make a business card no when you set up
a website no when you set up an llc well
yes
but people set up llc's and make no mo
no money when does your business start
the moment you make a dollar
and so
in 2009 when i started clear visual
media i wasn't making i wasn't even
monetized yet
but when was my did my business start
when i went and got a hundred bucks to
film a blues band at a local church
in los lake stevens washington
i collected a hundred bucks they wrote
it to sean cannell
i'm in business
the moment you make a sale the moment
you there's the moment you make some
income
and those early years this is true for
most businesses most businesses are not
profitable for a few years
18 to 24 months
why because you're reinvesting
your education gear equipment travel
product development
content
it takes time to make money
but you can start so so
everybody watching this right now can
make a decision right now
to say oh i'm not going to dabble
anymore it's time to dominate i'm in
business right now i'm a business owner
right now
like my youtube channel is a business
it's not a hobby
my social media presence is a business
it's not a hobby my personal brand is a
business it's not a hobby and i'm going
to start treating it serious
and even if it takes me two years three
years five years 10 years i'm going to
work my way through the cash flow
quadrants
and
i'm a business owner
and i started thinking that way years
before we saw what we're seeing today at
think media and i encourage you to think
the same smash like if you're getting
value today we're answering your
question if you got a question post four
question marks before and after it
and uh today's episode is brought to you
by growth video live i'm gonna take a
sip of water and i'll be right back in
one second this thing is your gateway to
get out of the thing that you complain
about but people would rather complain
about how it is than put in the work we
need to start understanding how big this
opportunity is because for everybody in
this room he will sit back in 20 30
years and regret if you didn't execute
in this era it has never been a better
time in the human race ever to actually
just go all in on you
regardless of what you're trying to
accomplish you've got to tell the world
about it this is now the world you're
not betting on this you're finished
[Music]
this is your golden era right now
there's never been a better time to be
here
[Music]
this is the greatest golden era of not
only business but life
i desperately want you to win
but this is on you
warning early bird pricing is ending at
midnight tonight so to get five percent
off the already discounted tickets at
growethvideolive.com
use the promo code gwvlshow
as you purchase your ticket there's a
couple different levels you can join us
virtually
you can join us virtually with the all
access pass which gives you access to
the third day which is a mastermind
environment much smaller environment
online think media team in zoom rooms
with you doing workshops getting clarity
together on that third day that's the
all access level or you can come in
person to las vegas at either a general
admission vip or platinum level three
levels all the same event with just
different features and you can see all
the details at grow with videolive.com i
do want to make sure if you're like i'd
really want to come but i'm going to
wait a week to get my ticket don't
because prices go up literally at
midnight tomorrow is may 1st can you
believe it it's april 30th right now and
so i highly recommend go to
growethvideolive.com
use the promo code grow gwvl show to get
five percent off just because you're
here on the grow with video live
show
if you haven't
pressed the like button
what are you thinking yeah i agree grow
a video live is gonna be insane and uh
can't wait for it
uh here we go lightning round
how do you get through creative block
i've just taken a month off
um number one yeah if you need a rest
tired eyes rarely see a bright future
sometimes the best thing to do with
creative block is take a nap but here's
some of the other things i like to do
take a walk
get the blood flow and get some oxygen
going one of the reasons i like running
is because running
they call it the runner's high i get
some of my best thinking my best ideas
sitting here at this desk
does not
help
come up with great ideas because the
blood is not flowing the oxygen is not
happening so get outside get into nature
to get out of creative block read a book
for real read a physical book
get in get in a vibe get some tea get
some coffee
get some essential oils going in a
humidifier light a candle clean up your
workspace
pull out a book pull out a journal and
just read you know the truth is you
should in my opinion
create more than you consume
because you're a content creator so you
got to be creating
but
don't underestimate
the consume part you are what you eat so
eat good content read some good books
they don't even have to be directly
related to what you do but i get ideas
when i read
books i get ideas when i read the bible
i get inspired when i
study other materials when i watch
youtube videos intentionally
you know
step outside of your niche a little bit
watch some content on youtube consume
content strategically in order to fill
your creative tank and then remix what
you've been consuming into your own
stuff
attend events i get inspired and they
don't have to just be like directly
related to your niche events just go
places go you know head into the city
walk through
uh some place cool go to an art exhibit
get into some different environments and
that'll help stimulate your creativity
and then
make sure that you have you know a
notepad
a physical little book um because
i've learned that
creativity can sometimes be hard to turn
on in the moment what you want to do is
24 7 get ready to capture the ideas
in the shower as you get out of the
shower if you're in bed i sometimes do
this and i think about something and i
go i'm so tired i don't want to write it
down i won't remember it tomorrow open
up my phone i write it down on my notes
app like capture the ideas 24 7 so when
you sit down and you need to be creative
you can just open up your notes and
there's all your ideas so i'll write
down youtube ideas throughout the day
and the week even though i might not
have another shoot for 10 days those are
some tips to get out of creative block
chess vibes i'm a one-man show but ready
to hire an editor can you share tips of
when you first hired an additional
person
um
there's different ways you could go
about it vid chops or like video husky
places like that um there's a uh
for some of those resources i recommend
checking out
uh think media tools
we actually use bid chops if you look at
some of the think media videos they are
edited by
chops
that's not right that's not right okay
look on screen now
and uh
thinkmediatools.com that's some of the
tools we use so so to save money to make
things simple something like vid chops
is great and there's a lot of the
different tools we use at
thinkmediatools.com
you can see that url on screen
um
i've i've hired local people so i hired
an intern for my church
ron like we had a relationship he wanted
to learn and i paid him in an amazon
gift card for a hundred bucks but he was
pumped like that was the agreement um
and so if you know someone locally you
could start off with them two different
ways you also could pay people you could
pay people
per hour but i i would prefer to just
pay them per project
because the nice thing about that
is you can um
just say listen
you know i want to pay you 100 bucks a
video and find somebody who could do
that or i want to pay you 50 bucks a
video then you just know that
four videos are gonna cost you two
hundred dollars that's one a week it's
200 a month and if you start getting
some adsense going
so yeah you can work locally you know
craigslist
indeed
zip recruiter like depending on what
level you want to be at but uh i
recommend probably something like
vid chops honestly to start and and
what's nice about that is you could
shoot your content and then just dropbox
it and like 24 hours turn around your
video is ready to upload and you get it
an editor dedicated to you
so eventually they'll get your flow and
you could really get into a flow where
you like just dropbox your footage have
the editor turn it around
you're good to go all right uh love that
hat you're my ideal client
if i make you some think media gear uh
yeah i mean
that'd be dope um
reach out uh okay let's see we got
how do you add the hashtags below the
video title
so all you have to do to add hashtags is
post them in the description
and uh anywhere and they'll show up up
to three
and whatever the first three in the
description are even though they're way
at the bottom here
they'll pop up below above so think
media nolan molt
uh what else could we do on here
uh uh
edit video so let's add okay
that's not good but yeah all you got to
do is add hashtags
hashtag whatever they are
put them in your description and the
first three up to three
will show up
inside uh above your title
um
check out our video about hashtags
search think media hashtag for strategy
on how to use hashtags because they can
kind of backfire like you wanna click on
your hashtags
uh we have two videos on them so here's
the videos i highly recommend
this is probably the one my gosh nolan
what are you doing with
324 000 views
what a legend
okay uh this won't will this post
everywhere i dropped it
right here from stream yard inside of my
my area over on facebook on my fan page
and on the in the chat
on
think media podcast channel there is the
link to that video from nolan very good
video about how you should strategically
be actually using hashtags
can i get a ticket for day two only as i
arrive from the uk
from uh
too late for day one you know there's
not much we could do
tickets are
much more affordable right now than they
will be the you know general mission by
the day of the event
it's 50 off right now
um but you can always reach out to us at
talkwiththink.com
um
and so
uh
i don't think there's anything we can do
but we'll see what the team says so go
ahead and talk with us at talk with
think dot com appreciate the question
rachel
how do you balance not giving too much
away for free
a person who makes quick uh cookbooks
can you give all the recipes away how
would you be consistent and give value i
think people overthink this
like the world's just so busy people
aren't watching all your stuff they're
not paying as much attention as you
think so give away great free content
you know
um
and
what people also like is they like
like the organization and and tactile
feel
because like
here's the truth
if you go to video influencers
specifically that the channel i did with
benji
and you watch every single interview and
every single video
in the entire history now mind you
we filtered out some of the stuff that
wasn't great it's not like every
interview was great
so you have to like do the filtering
yourself
but if you watched
300 hours of content
you could probably find every tip that's
in this book
but think about
the power of this book we took 300 hours
of content and we put it into a three
hour
audio book
we put it into
180 page book
so you get the right information
organized in a strategic way
all in one place
the book has sold 80 000 copies it's
been translated as a korean version it's
been translated into
i think seven or eight languages now
but
here's the point so we
over like a couple years gave a lot of
stuff away free like probably everything
but again maybe it was a clip from an
interview here was a clip so
people want the cookbook
because people want the book they don't
want to watch
300 hours of videos
they're not sure well what's which
information is outdated what stuff is
you know what i mean
and so then
your goal is to do the filtering
and that's also that's also one of the
powers of an online course is the same
thing as like you get all the right
steps all in order in the right place
everything filtered out
um all updated and in in our course
video ranking academy for example
there's a ton of stuff that we don't
share you know on youtube um
honestly it just it just goes super deep
but we give away a ton of free content
and by the way there is overlap but you
don't get the workbook on you know you
don't get the step-by-step
videos in order and that's what that's
why i think people you overthink it
because
you could give away a lot of free
content but it's a piece here it's a
piece there as it would be you're just
talking about like one piece of the
journey
what the goal of a book or an online
course is
all the steps in the right order all in
one place and this is what
people
especially smart people will do is they
pay for speed
they pay to save time
if you value your time you don't want to
dig around on youtube you want all the
answers all in one place you don't want
the ads you don't want anything else and
that's what you're investing in is
you're paying for speed because time is
money and so by the way the good news
her healthy home
is some people only want the free
information great but then there's going
to be others who go okay i love her
stuff and she has this one recipe oh she
has a quick cookbook they'll go straight
to the cookbook so you'll win in both
cases your brand will grow with good
free content and there'll be tons of
people that also get value and like dude
i just want to skip the line basically i
want to cut right to the front let me
just get the book let me just get the
cookbook let me save time i want to know
just how that creator
has distilled down
all the different lives they're doing
and videos they're doing and podcasts
are doing it i mean because it's a lot
of stuff that's kind of content
marketing
but if they've put it all into a system
all in one place
that's going to save me time
and
there could be no better investment in
my money
than to just shortcut my learning
and so uh that's what i'd recommend
all right any advice on how to grow a
channel hit like if you're getting value
today it's a saturday stream it's 3 55
p.m if you're on the replay hit me up
with replay fam if you're on the replay
we're an hour and 30 minutes into this
you're diehard if you're on the replay
and you're this far into the video so
let me know
yo sean
hashtag replay fam
die hard with a vengeance out here any
advice on how to grow our channel on
youtube to promote it we do car reviews
uh how to diy videos and exhaust videos
um i think you're probably doing it
right
i mean
if you're making tips that people want
and no
uh let me see here let me see here
let me see
where's your channel why can't i find it
eminem oh m and mnm car shepards
all right here we go
so
your thumbnails uh
i don't like this small font on the
thumbnails it's kind of hard to read
maybe is almost unnecessary because
honestly like the car is pretty dope
there you could almost zoom in a little
bit more
but like i know it's the 2022 mercedes
maybach
uh because it says in the title so i
don't even know if you need the text
uh on the thumbnail just thought i mean
they're fine cars are sexy like this is
i like this thumbnail is great you know
i'd consider the lighting in this
picture here
um
i'm kind of being i don't that's not
gonna make her break the channel but
like the yellow here pops the angle is
dramatic
um
that's just thumbnails though let's
success leaves clues let's see
uh
why
ask yourself why do these videos do well
and is
it seems like
is this just like for entertainment
value or is it how to because this just
is like saying hey this is what it
sounds like
you know it's the
it's what the revs sound like so if
people want to hear that that's like one
thing but i think you could be
doing a lot better if you had more
utility content or or if you thought
from utility like if you if you were
like
let's see here
uh golf mark six
uh
okay
exhaust
and let's see straight pops okay so this
one
revs install
okay
yeah i mean it seems like you probably
know your niche like success leaves
clues
the production value is pretty fire here
what's going on here
dude i just like this paint let's zoom
in
okay this looks like a promo video
sheesh
black on black dude
what do we got are we talking about
uh
wow okay this isn't your channel this
pretty fire that's i mean 1.1 million
views that's some production values
interesting there
and and i don't know why that one got so
many views so
so i mean uh i'm just kind of doing a
flyover here
i would look at
why you only upload one video on the
last
okay
like upload more videos would be a good
way to grow your channel
um because you are getting good views
uh yeah i think where to promote it
get in you know just keep spreading your
brand in places
uh
discords facebook groups if relevant
you know as you guys get known for what
you're showing and what you're doing
um
car like you're just off to the right
track and i my thought
is uh you're definitely off to the right
off to a good start
and and partly i mean you only been
doing this for a year and i think that's
half the secret you've got some 14 000
views 4.8 000 views
so
final tips
improve the thumbnails success leaves
clues car photography is tough because
there's a lot of cars are big there's a
lot of car to show
how do you show with the thumbnail you
know look at different angles
uh and whatever to think and look at the
top viewed videos to kind of think about
how things are framed up whatever in
some cases like i don't know if like you
guys both need to be in it and the car
and whatever so you know thinking about
thumbnail composition thinking about
titles and the angles of the video
you're doing
um
studying maybe some competitors and
looking at some of the topics and what
they're doing but here's my big my big
takeaway for you
you've only been doing this for a year
and you haven't even posted that many
videos
keep going
like you
i mean you want to grow it but it's
growing
like that's all you know you get 8 000
views a month
on the other side i think there could be
some youtube short opportunities for you
i think that um
posting more and continuing to just
double down on like what what's getting
43 000 views because if you could remake
obviously easier said than done but if
you could remake this over and over then
you're going to keep getting 10 20 30
000 views because you're doubling down
on a particular type of video that's
gonna drive your subscribers up it's
going to drive up you know results on
the channel and then the more videos you
have out there the more chance you have
for breakout videos
and
game over
we talk about
16 types of videos in our video ranking
academy program
and that's i think your final
opportunity and and friends get ready to
take notes because i would recommend
um
writing some of these things down i'll
tell you whichever ones i can
do off the top of my head but in any of
our channels
experiment with different video types
okay what do i mean
one answer specific questions
how do i install a certain exhaust how
do i fix one piece of the car answer
specific questions
two review specific products
such and such
catless downpipe review
that is trending review specific
products okay three uh teach specific
skills how to
um you know
reprogram the chip make the chip i don't
know if you could do that you know how
to how to tune
the chip in the golf
okay
teach specific skills how to tune it
yourself
best settings
something like that
but then you can get into like trend
surfing and influence surfing you could
react see that's a react format you can
react you could react to the new trailer
of that volkswagen releases about
something that infinity releases you can
react to it
um
opc other people's content
um
and so
influence surfing you could react to a
particular influencer that has a
particular car that's relevant to the
types of cars you're you're
um you know
ultimately into and this kind of stuff
you're doing and then you tap into
something like youtube shorts
and and youtube shorts could go viral if
maybe you do just flex the sound you
flex some dope angles
a compilation of
the apr catalyst downpipe sound
people start sharing it like oh dang
this car is sick oh listen to that is it
shareable
shorts feed
blows it up and so
the takeaway and again we teach this
in depth and that's we're uploading a
whole new section of
our uh there's another good one randy
vra student the versus video strategy
this exhaust versus that exhaust when
someone's about to make a buying
decision
um this car versus that car as someone's
about to make a buying decision and
people specifically at that moment are
down to like two different choices and
they they end up picking one
and so um
we uh
we we teach the if you want to learn a
little bit more about this i think think
masterclass.com is typically
where it is uh yeah right now
when is this happening hey we got a
class coming up
may 3rd tuesday heather's going to be
teaching exactly what i'm describing
right here live
if you haven't heard about this which
how could you uh because i'm just
learning about this right now
um and so yeah we do these from time to
time the next one is heatherlive
register
at
syncmasterclass.com
and um yeah if you want to go a little
bit deeper into some of this stuff and
there's the url but
um
different here's the punch line the
content formats
like the video types so you said
your promise is car enthusiasts all that
kind of stuff so if you're watching this
you know who's the content for we get in
a rut
why can't you do a react video if your
subscribers would like it your target
audience why can't you review a product
if your target audience would enjoy that
why can't you experiment with different
content formats
um and so
yeah this master class isn't through
facebook it's on a private watch page so
you don't have to be on facebook to be a
part of it
um
thinkmasterclass.com we just send you
the link in your email
to uh to this the next one's with
heather um and i do these
it's it's maybe every two weeks or every
other week we go
live and so the next one is happening
may 3rd
with heather taurus it's live 4 pm we do
a giveaway we'll give away a live
streaming setup with a camera and
lights and all that kind of cool stuff
it's on a private viewing page it's
tuesday may 3rd 4 p.m pacific standard
time you can see all the details at
thinkmasterclass.com
and that's kind of just a preview of
ultimately you know what we teach in
depth inside of our video ranking
academy uh program but again totally
free like whether you ever want to join
us inside of our program or not highly
recommend you check out that uh free
class
dude my voice is on the marathon sprint
today looking forward to seeing you guys
at gwvl any thoughts on my channel just
started
last year smart i'm not doing channel
reviews
please do not give any super chats for
channel reviews
i am not doing channel reviews i am
going to do one channel review but i am
not doing any more channel reviews
but really smart to take the bold move
throw in a super chat and uh and this is
the last channel review okay here we go
um love the thumbnails i mean a lot of
intuition here simplicity i love the
blue here smart to have your face
on you know the plain white card you can
obviously put any text on that
one there is like the the three
the rule of three and thumbnails your
face the text
and the retirement fund
clean i like it
uh great great thumbnails some simple
i love them
um success leaves clues make part twos
so
secret strategies sure look worked well
your secret fire strategy the secret
fire strategy
obviously these videos have had time to
keep getting views too
so success leaves clues make part twos
um you know what what are the top viewed
videos teaching you double down on them
um
and then a lot of what i would probably
suggest let's see let me check this out
here
let's turn this off
let's let's add the audio back and let's
review one of your videos
all right
it's one welcome to five side chat my
name is psy i want to answer the most
common question i get as a financial
coach it's one million dollars enough to
retire early the short answer is yes the
long answer is it depends
really good opening you know i typically
say don't start with introducing
yourself but he got it done in like two
seconds um
and
that's kind of cool i also gotta admit i
am kind of fascinated by your background
that why do schools on mars refuse to
teach math
it lacks atmosphere
i like having a little bit of like hold
my attention millionaire next door i
like it
in this video i'm gonna break down the
retirement bucket strategy and how to
determine if one million dollars is
enough to retire early great here our
goal is also cash to pay for it so you
know we can learn a lot from
how do you create content but then like
show me something teach me something you
start drawing some frameworks out so
according to forbes
this is great generate more cash flow
than we would eventually good use of
chapters properties time codes and
chapters fourth bucket is our pension
funds and great great
last stack is down almost nice and then
what do you want to happen i'm assuming
you're doing some kind of personal
finance stuff so
let's see here we go
get your free fire resources
uh you know i this landing page could be
a lot better
because you don't want all of this stuff
this is all distracting so think about
like if you want my name email and phone
uh like how much are you making on these
ads man get the ads off the who cares
about the ads
um
cause this is a distraction so so here i
land on your site
now i want some shoes
okay i don't even care about this by the
way just got half a penny from me
because i clicked on shoes i don't care
about um so now i'm gone
okay
next issue and the ads are not even
loading so that's interesting refresh
okay if i read left to right
fire side chat financial coaching
services
social media fireside chat on youtube
home about coaching services
login oh get your free now obviously
it's dead center but think about this
like this is all unnecessary
get your free fire resources this also
is weak
because i don't know what this means i
don't know what fire means
i don't know this isn't like you should
call me out you should say
are you ready to what results like what
is
what are these resources going to get me
let's get to know you once you submit
this form we'll send you the link to the
fire resources
so dumb it down for me
like
uh get your free retirement plan
like
one step to one million you know like
summarize it up for me and and
potentially use a page
you know if this is wordpress or
something what is this wix
uh
wix is fine
[Music]
but
see if wix has landing pages wix landing
pages
okay uh
yeah and use a landing page template
so
let's see
let's see
uh
this stuff all sucks
for landing pages like you're gonna want
something way better than this
so notice some of the ads that came up
let's see what ads came up this isn't
your biggest problem i know you want a
channel review but uh sorry i'm
distracted here leadpages
naturally
i move my website to wix leechpit okay
okay pages
so you just want like
i hate to show you this because it's
kind of weak but here's here's here's
what it kind of should look like
uh thinkgearguide.com
we need to update it that's the thing
it's outdated it's 20 21.
like get the online gear video gear
guide free that could even be better but
like you're actually going to get
something and notice this page there's
no like
contact us
no
ads
no like distractions
like
the goal is to call out like why is this
valuable and inside this free guide
you'll learn
how to select the right setup for your
ideal video needs the exact gear you'll
need whether you're just starting out or
a season pro the best cameras for every
budget enter your name and email phone
if you want let's get going keep it
simple this is on kajabi
but
assuming because this is great and
you're doing great and as you continue
to get people in assuming my thought
is you want to ultimately help people
with coaching okay
financial this is clearer
but even still all of this stuff's up
here
so if you could simplify this
down
and even maybe maybe give me an image
it's just it's it
what it feels like that all that kind of
stuff could use some work by the way
grow video live is gonna be great
because we'll touch on this business
side of things
you want to remove friction you want to
think about
basically
the ui ux it's the
user interface and it's the user
experience
and you want
it to be super simple and maybe that's
why sometimes jot form or sometimes it
could be you know let's get started
first of all what's your name and like
it could be a progressive survey
whatever that's not the point of
reviewing your channel but smash like if
you're getting geeking out on some of
this more niche stuff because here's my
thought
is even with how good you're doing right
now i feel like maybe i don't know how
good business is but i feel like
uh
things can be
incredibly great for you
you know for whatever it is that you
want to achieve because you don't need
huge numbers because i would assume you
have a business model that can really
help people with personal finance
investment or whatever your business
model is
so everything looks good here you know
make your video you know keep leveling
up your videos get one percent better um
success leaves clues i'm not sure if
you're part of you know like our video
ranking academy fam but like
lots of stuff there you're relatively
early in the journey i think
good job of being consistent too this is
what i like to see we're out here
in a year's time and a year ago and we
got some videos friends
respect the hustle
fire sight chat man
pumping out the videos
stay inconsistent there's a little
influence surfing a little dave ramsey
in the thumbnail come on you know what
we're talking about little elon and
bezos in the thumbnail come on influence
surfing
kick the tires and light the fires big
daddy
it's time to get it going
do you see this this is the respect the
hustle a little bit of youtube shorts
happening and you know what this all
adds up to friends 32
981 views
and we're just getting started
but
you know what this points me to as the
unlock of the day i hope that was
somewhat valuable and let me know if you
have any follow-up questions anybody as
we uh
but you know what this makes me think
about
this makes me just think about how
important business models are
and i'll illustrate with this especially
if you're a business owner or you have
something you want to happen you want
you want to you want someone to buy your
book you want someone to buy your course
you want to sell a house
you want someone to you know you want to
help them with their finances you want
them to sign up for fitness classes with
your guitar lessons you want them to
join your discord you want them to go
somewhere do something patreon
what most people focus on is just
getting more and more and more and more
and more youtube views more and more and
more youtube subscribers which is great
and we're here to help you with that
but people
it's like you have a leaky bucket
everyone just wants to keep turning on
more
water but there's holes in your bucket
like your experience on your website
signing up for your forms and all that
kind of stuff and i heard a stat
how long
is the average follow-up time
for a lead which is someone signing up
to connect with an agent on zillow where
you buy homes how long does it take on
average average
for agents to follow up with a lead that
comes in on zillow when someone sees the
house and they're like i'd love to talk
to an agent and they enter their name
and their phone number in their email
how long
36 hours
what the heck are we talking about
it takes over a day for someone to
follow up in the lead and zillow is
sending them leads
okay watch this though
80
of leads on zillow
never get followed up with
what
you know that people agents pay
upwards of a hundred and twenty five
dollars
to 225 dollars for every single lead
that they get on zillow and they don't
even follow up
so you have this opportunity on your
youtube channel friend it's already huge
59 people just watched your newest video
141 people watched your video eight days
ago i'm speaking to you as a business
owner as an entrepreneur
let's growth hack your channel
but let's also make sure
that you got your back end right the
fortunes in the follow up
fix your leaky bucket
and man i can't even imagine if i'm a
real estate agent i'm like hemorrhaging
cash like zillow's fine they're like
collecting the money to send you the
leads they're 80 percent of agents
that's a that's a true stat
eighty percent of leads on zillow never
get followed up with maybe you've done
it before i've like wanted to like get
some info on a property you like fill
out the information not only that i
actually hope to hear from somebody in
the next 30 minutes to 60 minutes
if i'm about i'm about to buy a house
you know what i mean i want to sell my
house
and and so fix
the leaky
bucket justin brown my man
what is it sunday in australia we're out
here
primal video good to see you
and uh
let's see here will skipping long-form
content and uploading one short a day
instead whose content will represent my
niche eventually get me into browsing
suggested gina
both and i think that um i think kind of
i think it's going to be hard to build
deep relationships with shorts
um
i hope it depends on your model it
depends on what you want to do
but uh
i think the bigger question
can if if shorts is what you can start
with then then stardom
i wouldn't say it's either or
i mean uploading one short i wouldn't
instead is the word i don't like
not instead
i would like you to do both
i think there's different content that
serves different purposes longer form
content this is longer form is an hour
and 53 minutes are we getting to know
each other
but we do shorts too
so
uh we get into brows with three minute
videos shorts with 30 minute videos i
get into brows with 45 minute live
stream replays this probably won't get
into browse or maybe it will um but it's
it's not instead
gina
it's both and
should i do lives or shorts or or
long-form youtube videos
yes
well should i do youtube videos or
should i also if i create vertical
videos should i post them on instagram
and tick tock too because i have the
content
yes
should i post a video today or not
you should post a video today
what if i have to like take a week off
though will the world end it might
if you take a week off youtube
the world is depending on you your
upload schedule who cares if you got to
take a week off take a week off
if you can upload a short this week
and even you're looking for like a
mathematical there's no secret
nicholas cage national treasurer
indiana jones
and the secret
of the lost ark treasure to be found
on uploading one short a day
that is not there's not a formula
ooh
if i could just
if i upload seven shorts if anyone ever
tells you
listen i've cracked the code
if you upload 21 shorts in 21 days
at 2 21 in the afternoon
that are 21 seconds each
it'll crack it'll break the youtube
algorithm
and then all of a sudden the shorts feed
will start to reverberate with views
it doesn't matter what the content is
all of a sudden your videos will start
to rise
i call it my 2121 2121 strategy it
doesn't matter
uploading a short a day
gives you more chances
for one of those to blow up
but there's no like secret
upload a short a day
seven days a week and that you know
and so
it's both and it's not either or
but i agree claire
[Music]
21 seconds
i uploaded 21 shorts in 21 days and they
were 21 seconds each
then all of a sudden i got 22 checks in
the mail
and each one was foot for 21
i said this was weird
so i looked at my phone and it was 2 21
in the after it's 4 21. oh my gosh
there's something to this
[Laughter]
literally
claire we we just cracked the code on
the inner oh it's 4 22.
shoot
the 21-21-21 strategy matthew
we hit it
i cannot believe
oh
just ridiculous
i'm trying to be nick nimmin out here
i'm at one hour and 57 minutes on the
afternoon
james hey you know what i'm gonna answer
this question in a second i needed some
water uh hey we have an event coming up
by the way if you haven't heard about it
watch this video have you heard the most
recent youtube statistics right now
being a content creator is the fastest
growing small business youtube paid
creators over 14 billion dollars in the
last year from adsense alone wow youtube
generated more revenue than netflix in
2020 and forbes said that by year end
the creator economy is going to
experience 5x growth in the next 12
months so how can you take advantage of
this opportunity to start making money
with your youtube channel and even going
full time working from home we'll show
you how at growth video live 2022
conference just go to
growwithvideolive.com
or click the link in this post or in the
description to secure your limited time
discounted ticket if you want to learn
the best new strategies for getting
views on youtube making money online and
crushing it on social media then don't
miss this life-changing event during
this two-day event you'll learn exactly
how to grow and monetize an online
business using video you're going to
learn directly from proven industry
experts like gary vaynerchuk patrick
bette david vanessa lau pat flynn
chalene johnson and more you'll meet
hundreds of other creative entrepreneurs
just like you and connect with leading
brands in our industry join us in person
in las vegas or virtually from anywhere
in the world secure your ticket at
growethvideolive.com and take the fast
track to dominating the next decade with
youtube and social media marketing go to
grow with video live dot com or click
the link in this post or in the
description to secure your limited time
discounted ticket right now
yes growth video live is 23 days away
however
early bird pricing is ending at midnight
tonight if you're with me live here
friends
it is 4 24 p.m in the afternoon on the
last day of april
2020. tomorrow is may 1st can you
believe how fast this year is going i
have a baby due on september 3rd
my wife will actually be giving birth
not me and
we are excited that has nothing to do
with the fact that if you want to get
the best price on your ticket for growth
video live you can join us virtually or
in person in las vegas and you can get
an additional five percent off just
because you're a part of the growth
video live show which is the show you're
watching right now on either facebook or
youtube use the code gwvlshow
when you're checking out at
growthvideolive.com there's multiple
different ticket levels but seriously if
you're on the fence
don't wait because you can save big and
join all kinds of awesome creators and
entrepreneurs like gary vaynerchuk alex
and layla hermosie patrick bett david
ryan pineda brett knudson vanessa lau
emily baker heather torres the rocho
live jasmine star chalene johnson
anthony o'neil omar altocory aaron on
demand
john revere andrew jick pat flynn evan
carmichael dylan vegas benji travis matt
von drager matt stefania pace morby
ricegum sebastian angus sean holliday
tanner fox josette
pamita
man we out here grow with videolive.com
um
save big and uh right now again by the
time we get to the actual
event tickets are 50 off like general
admission right now it's 497 bucks
but that is a
an investment in your business in your
future and it's right off as an
educational
event for your business um but tickets
at the door for general admission which
will be sold out or about 60 percent
full right now but they're gonna be
they're 997. and fair enough this is a
high-level
business video marketing social video
event where you're going to be learning
the latest strategies from frankly the
greatest speaker lineup in kind of the
youtubepreneur world the entrepreneur
business world teaching video that i've
ever seen so
um i highly recommend save
over 50 off on tickets plus an
additional five percent off right now at
growwithvideolive.com
and use the promo code because you are
part of the show if you have a question
uh post four question marks before and
after
the question and i would love to connect
with you
um
the lineup is crazy four or five
question marks before or after let me
know
and i got some questions coming in i'm
starring some questions
three
two
one back in lightning room mode document
sharing respiratory what do you
recommend for sending files and docs to
live stream yes
uh dropbox um
google docs on google docs we'll do show
outlines and you can make the link
publicly viewable and we'll put the show
outline on google docs
and send that to a guest add people to
it so they can collaborate on the dock
and all the notes are saved in the back
end
for our team we use slack
we can create slack channels with teams
we're collaborating with or other
individuals
um we do use dropbox to actually
transfer video files i believe we have
we use a business account and we have
unlimited storage because we upload a
lot of footage like we have an editor in
canada and toronto named steph
uh we send him footage to edit
and so uh that's that's typically how we
send files and docs around email things
like that i hope that was your question
when when do i get my ticket for growth
video live i bought it in january uh
did you buy it our bundle because if you
did that then um
just go to uh
talkwiththink.com is probably the best
best place to go if you're if you're it
should be in your email just make sure
you chuck your check your junk
promotions in gmail or hotmail spam you
know promotions tab
search sean cannell and all those places
because we're delivering you your
tickets uh via
uh email but if you have a question head
over to
talkwiththink.com cue up a call it'll be
this following week
but our team would love to connect with
you and get you all sorted to make sure
your ticket is uh good to go or
let you know uh yeah we're there to help
talk with think.com
would be a great place to connect with
us
uh natasha
uh what's the deal with video
influencers channel is that something
you and benjy are still working on we've
we've kind of sunsetted it and uh so we
are not still working on that channel um
we do have the second edition of youtube
secrets coming out in a short time so
they'll probably be a stream or two uh
but he's
he's gone into uh benjitravis.com he's
doing some coaching stuff uh really
doubling down of course on their vlog
and think media is also it's gnarly you
know in a good way we have 25 people
working for think
i'm a ceo and as family both of us are
dads so as
a family man both of us uh really
prioritizing how many projects we can
focus on your business is like a baby
your youtube channel is like a baby i
learned this too from michael stelzner a
friend of mine he said you know
kind of like how many kids
do you want to parent
it's a really good question he's like
and every new project you start is kind
of like a child
so let's say you have a child you got to
parent them you're thinking about them
let's say you have another child i got
another one on the way but then watch
you're actually you got a youtube
channel think media now maybe it's more
dynamic like ours it's actually a pretty
scalable scaled up business
our event growth video live is like
another child
you gotta nurture the event take care of
it
you know
and then video influencers is like
another child so at some point i think
in order to do more effectively it has
to do with doing less uh 19 kids and
counting you know sure you may be
comparing 19 kids you got to just
discern your bandwidth and michael
stelzner's advice was he was like if you
start something new like a new project
and so video influencers uh
we we decided to
focus on less projects so yeah we
haven't uploaded a video there i'm
focusing heavily on on think media
growth video live sean bradley sonia
canel
my health you know and uh who knows
though it's it's still there and and we
might circle back and and we'll
definitely do a couple live streams
there at least once youtube secret
second edition comes out
shortly
can i use memoji for the personal touch
as a faceless channel but keeping some
anonymity i think you could i don't know
if you've connected i don't know if
that's like a v tuber type of a
thing uh but you should definitely
connect with
uh
yeah it's kind of a v tuber type of a
thing right okay
so you know one of our video ranking
academy i know you're a part of video
ranking academy
what's your name uh
madeline
youtuber
she's like
i don't know if that's the same thing
you're doing but she's doing some pretty
cool stuff
uh how to be a youtuber how to be a
youtuber
let's see if we can find her channel
i think it's a thing and i think you
could keep
some anonymity
uh where's her channel though
do you are you familiar with all this
sci-fi sci-fi
yeah she could be a she'll be a growth
video live can you imagine if she walked
into grow a video live as an avatar
like as a walking cartoon
that'd be amazing
so um
yeah like she's also got some great
tutorials about
how to do things like how to add
movement to your accessories and stuff
so
i i think it's entirely up to you
um to
uh
to you could do this kind of thing and i
think in the gaming niche
uh it definitely could work really well
and so um
yeah go for it
uh
yeah
saya fire
in the house
yeah like a v tuber
i would i would do it
i would do it hey can you hit like
and
uh
let me know where you're watching from
and what you're sipping on
varus is watching the replay vera i'm
here live
we're we're meted out right now because
this isn't even the replay but it's
actually kind of cool like we thought
it was i'm still live but like
if you're watching this on the replay
i'm not but i am at this exact moment
and so for the 132 people that are here
i am here live
okay
um we have a baby due may 23rd i need to
change virtual access to virtual on
demand
uh randall that's super legit that's a
really good reason so hit up talk with
think dot com we would we would take
care of you regardless like you could
hit us up and be like listen
here's what happened um i had a baby
literally that day and i you know i
couldn't actually watch virtually is it
possible to get the recordings
yes uh i it is absolutely possible and
that is the greatest
uh request we've had and i am here to
honor that for you uh congratulations by
the way excited for you
um all right about to start
and have a nice thumbnail template from
canva keep it the same with different
picture and text or totally different
thumbnails every time
so
i think that when i go to a channel
and every thumbnail looks the same it
starts to drone on
i think if you could all if you
alternated through four different color
backgrounds that would be helpful like
red blue
you know yellow
but i'm a big fan of variety because
otherwise your library just kind of all
blends together
and if the only thing different is like
text like it all just kind of becomes
the same
um you could try it for a while though
and
it doesn't have to be a totally
different thumbnail
but
you know
i know that it's a learning curve and
and i understand i'm much further along
in my learning curve
but canva is insane like again i made
this
thumbnail for today's live stream by
just looking up a template throwing in a
picture and then like picking some words
and it probably took four minutes before
i went live today and there's a million
other
you know
let's
welcome to thumbnail training with sean
cannell
let's
make a thumbnail
in under two minutes
that's fresh here we go open up
canva.com
go to youtube thumbnail
and open up some of the templates
then what you're going to do is just
find something that looks good to you
and one of the huge assets you're going
to want is some pre-done photos that
would be nice
and so i have all of these thumbnails
ready which is a huge asset
uh but this is going to help us so then
i'm going to delete that guy and insert
me
and i would eventually recommend
investing in
the higher level of canva because you
can use
the
edit image tool and do the background
remover
and you'll just see how quick and fast
this is
with just doing that kind of for you
um and
then uh where are we at
30 seconds 45 seconds in
and there's like a zillion templates
here right okay great
scale up old shawnee here
cool
how to create good video i think we're
ready i mean done this could be if i was
it was about that but let's say like
um
let's see here
youtube
youtube
shorts
uh
tips
good how do i get okay
the background's kind of in the way so
let me move me out of the way i hope i
can find me again
short tips
um i like that little clicker
yeah
great
all right can we call could we say that
i'm done although what i would do can i
as i would
move this up and make this nice and big
and move this guy up too
okay
are you all having fun
i know we're over two minutes but
okay great
i like i like size
all right
all right i'm making a video on youtube
shorts tomorrow because i want to use
this
amazing all right share download
download
okay three minutes two minutes
so
like crushing excuses maybe definitely
taking the time to uh
here's the final let's let's observe it
there you go is it good bad
indifferent good can you give me a scale
from one to ten on the rating of this
thumbnail
five out of ten six out of ten seven out
of ten what would you change what do you
like about it
um
like
you'll speed up over time uh and
you can spend you know by the way that
took like three minutes you could spend
15
you could spend an hour doing your next
four thumbnails for your next four
videos
and you have canvas so you should be
good to go so yeah i think
i would switch it up every once in a
while
because again if they all look the same
if i go to your library your last 50
videos i'm not going to see much
distinction between them
so uh what'd you all think of old
thumbnail
tutorial there nine hey
i'm i'm not just fishing for compliments
oh retro neuralgia i appreciate it
though thank you nikki and so
uh ooh claire got the 10 out of 10
fun so you know yeah canva.com and by
the way
like i think you can get a discount from
us we do have an affiliate link
one of the best investments you can make
in your youtube business is kava
bigmediatools.com
including some thumbnail software
all kinds of what is that
thinkmediatools.com
let's look over there
thinkmediatools.com
kind of stuff we love to use let's see
uh adobe premiere um i would recommend
if you want simpler video editing
software though
simplest way to get started editing
is a mac
with imovie
and then when you're ready go to final
cut but if you want the fancy stuff we
we use adobe premiere pro
uh rev for captions femora we have a
couple different recommendations on here
bid chops if you want you know help
editing story blocks for v-rolls good
uh music epidemic sounds our favorite
for sure
uh you really get the most bang for your
buck and it can be a lot less
depending on your subscribers and things
like that which is kind of cool
we have
vidiq of course amazing live streaming
tool stream yard one of our favorite so
again if you want to check out our
favorite tools thinkmediatools.com
and uh again canva
uh is out here and so you could get a
free pro trial
which is nice
um and the pro feature that's where you
get like that background removal again
here's here's what i did in preparation
for this live stream
i
i it it took two minutes i didn't even
know what i was i just i don't know is
it good i don't know i just
wanted to go live this afternoon
thinkmediatools.com check out canva
all right um
drop four question marks before after
your question
uh lumafusion is is great
um
i actually highly recommend if you are
going ipad or iphone
friends
check out your boy omar with the
lumafusion tutorial for beginners
he would call it the best 4k video
editing app for iphones and ipads
and i think i'd agree so i'll drop that
link for you
if you're specifically going ipad
editing or iphone editing i'm glad you
brought that up tay lumafusion for sure
is is what i would go with
and i learned about that from omar and
he's got some great videos on it [ __ ] is
great too as well for graphic design
sony vegas
great as well
um
smash
liker
and share the stream let me see if i can
get to some of your question mark
questions before and after the question
so i can see your question with the
question marks before and after the
oh someone did awakening mission did a
qq i found it
all right here we go
advice about starting a music commentary
video podcast on youtube one of our
students is doing pretty good with this
leonardo taurus
um
but there's issues and and meaning
uh
what are those issues copyright so you
can do it and there's ways you kind of
get around it
but
you're going to run into if you're using
copyrighted music specifically
it's tough and so yeah he does music
reactions
um let's see you know reacting to josh
carroll's
firefly reaction chris staple reaction
so you can see what he's doing he's
doing well he's got some brand deals
going some other stuff
you got to figure out the business model
but uh
yeah
uh i mean you're also saying a music
commentary podcast so listening to the
music or you're just commentating on the
music
um i like it but you gotta ask you know
anthony centeno is one of the big he
does album reviews
um
kind of figure out your angle figure out
you know the value of it but it can work
and so i don't know if you've ever seen
anthony centeno
the internet's busiest music nerd
success leaves clues look at kind of
what others are doing but yeah no i
think it could work you got to think
about the copyright thing but people are
finding ways around that so i think you
could learn from that i need advice on
how to shoot vlog style film angles
so
um
i'll share a link with you ingrid
and let's see uh
i would say that
uh how to shoot b-roll from omar great
video
uh so i dropped that for you in the
facebook you're over on the think media
podcast youtube so you're good to go you
should see that link just posted for you
uh
i always have trouble making my exports
look clean
do you use a media encoder
yeah you can use adobe media encoder i
don't know if you're in premiere
sometimes lesser software caps
your your expert export settings um
most softwares you may need to go into
advanced settings or say go manual don't
let them do it for you because they'll
mess you up
and look up
the best set it like it gets really
geeky but here's what you do
so if you're gonna go to
if you have premiere imovie or something
and you can get to manual settings
you're like what are all these numbers
copy
youtube's recommended upload settings
so you go okay what should i call it an
mp4 all right it's an mp4 all right what
should the audio codec be i don't know
what this stuff means okay aac lc okay
what's the video codec what the heck is
all of this stuff
h.264
all right what should the frame rate be
uh and then you pick one which this this
gets a little interesting
because
if you
um
is
literally i feel like
a band of orcs from lord of the rings
are coming into our neighborhood with
giant drums like is that what's
happening right now like
[Music]
could be i don't know how much longer we
have friends
people mess up their videos because you
shoot in 25 frames you throw it into a
24 frames project you export it at 48
and then it looks like crap on the other
side so one of the keys there is you
want to just have it be consistent and
that's consistent workflow in terms of
your frame rate
your bit rate this is a huge key this
could be why it looks like crap
because
you're exporting it at too low of a bit
rate
and so if you're gonna upload you know
uh a
30 frames or 24 frames a second video
and it's 1080p you need to make sure
your bitrate is at least eight megabytes
per second
and so sometimes what's happening is
whatever software you're using is giving
you like crap bit rate and it makes it
look bad and then if it's more like 60
frames it's even higher
um
and then
your aspect ratio could be wrong too
like and what people do is they like
treat their video like jello they like
shoot it widescreen they edit it wrong
and it's like squished and then they
like export it and like it's jacked the
frame rates janky audio sounds sketch
and i hope i'm not i might have just
confused you more
uh but that is all workflow questions of
course the goal
is to like shoot on your iphone throw it
in imovie export it and like the goal of
apple and and filmora is to make some of
this stuff easy
uh but
but uh
copy copy the best settings and and
eventually you'll learn this stuff and
just fix just keep working on it and
eventually you'll be like dang my videos
are looking crispy man i'm doing it
right i'm exporting my stuff right
um any video editors out here i just
shared the longest link
in terms of
uh the link to the page the youtube help
page i was just talking about
yeah final cut has great rendering speed
i agree
uh i finally caved in i went 4k 24
shooting 100 megabytes a second
exporting at 35 megabytes i bet that's
crispy creator people
oh my gosh
i bet that's super crispy
great job uh yeah when i do slow-mo at
60 frame but a 24 timeline so you're
you're good you're i mean if you if you
already know that kind of stuff you
probably just have a few things to dial
in what software are you using
let me know
what your software is
because
if you have those features
that would be some of the things to look
for
hey if you're just joining us my name is
sean cannell rhymes with youtube channel
this is the grow with video live
show
um and today's episode is brought to you
by growth video live if you didn't hear
wherever you are in the world you can
join us on may 23rd and 24th to learn
from gary vaynerchuk patrickbetdavid
myself and the think media team about
how do you use video to grow your
business grow your personal brand make
money make a difference in fact check
out this video to learn a little bit
about this event this thing is your
gateway to get out of the thing that you
complain about but people would rather
complain about how it is than put in the
work we need to start understanding how
big this opportunity is because for
everybody in this room you will sit back
in 20 30 years and regret if you didn't
execute in this era it has never been a
better time in the human race ever to
actually just go all in on you
regardless of what you're trying to
accomplish you've got to tell the world
about it this is now the world you're
not betting on this you're finished
[Music]
this is your golden era right now
there's never been a better time to be
here
this is the greatest golden era of not
only business but life
i desperately want you to win
but this is on you
if you're not betting on this you're
finished if you're not betting on this
you're finished if you're not that's
garyvee's line i love that line though i
mean he's right because honestly
uh this is where people's attention is
of course desktop computers smart tvs
but all of us are just going around all
day looking at our phones and you have a
chance to of course share your content
on youtube on instagram on tick tock on
facebook on linkedin on pinterest on
snapchat um and master these video
platforms to share messages that matter
and we're talking all about it at growth
video live here's the deal early bird
pricing is ending at midnight tonight
may 1st is tomorrow this is live at this
moment if you're on the replay it may be
too late but get your early bird pricing
before the prices go up
plus get an extra five percent off
because you're watching the show right
now
so because you're here on the grow a
video live show your promo code is
gwvl show
use that promo code at the website when
checking out whether virtual or in
person
for grow a video live happening in vegas
at the end of may
2022 can't wait to see you going to be
absolutely incredible awakening mission
says love love love gary vee he's going
to be there in person someone asks is he
virtual or is he in person he's in
person
it's going to be amazing uh to have him
sharing of course he's always on the
bleeding edge
of uh what's happening in social media
in digital media
and um can't wait
all right
a youtuber with 70 000 subscribers 75
wants me to record videos for their
course in exchange for exposure to their
channel i currently have five subs
should i charge them money for this
you gotta figure it out i mean just do
some math on paper
like how many hours of work are you
gonna do for them how long will the
project take that's scope what's the
scope of the project
um
try to evaluate what that would be worth
you know what you could ask them too you
could say
how much would you just charge me for
this shout out
and they go a million dollars you come i
don't know if that's a good deal
so like a shout out like a dedicated
video that might be worth
if by the way hopefully your audiences
are aligned because you don't want to
get shouted out by a channel that's
going to bring you subscribers that
won't care about your content
but assuming that's good like maybe
maybe it's worth 2500 bucks maybe it's
worth five grand so then how much would
you charge to make those videos
how how long will that take is it one
day and then you edit them
and so
there it's a win-win for you
there's a level of potential risk it
could be amazing for you or not as good
but if you get to
do sweat equity
that's always great if you got a little
extra time right now it's a side hustle
you're going to get some promo if
audiences are aligned sounds compelling
to me
but again if they want you to record
videos for their course and their course
is going to be
274
seven minute videos with b-roll
captions
titles and it's gonna take you
you know four months
to shoot and edit all of the videos for
their course
that probably doesn't sound worth it for
me so i don't know the scope of what
that even means so i think scope getting
through the details would be huge and
then and then eventually just making a
decision
if you're early in your career you want
to be saying yes if you're further in
your career you actually want to start
saying no and what i mean is when i was
early in my career i said yes to every
client did a lot of them kind of suck
and underpay me yes but i built my
portfolio i honed my skills
early on in my career i would fly and do
event coverage
because i wanted to get in the room at
events and get around other leaders and
learn and get a free ticket because i
went and filmed at events
did it take a lot of time and they like
paid my expenses but i got paid like
crap
but i wanted the learnings i wanted the
lessons i wanted the networking i wanted
the exposure today
i say no to a lot more things i'm busy
my time is truly worth more because of
what we earn inside of our company and i
can be very selective of where i spend
my time so if you're early on in your
career i would do some math but i would
probably say yes i would find a way to
make it work because the pro anything to
do to get some promo to build up to
hustle to biz dev to do some joint
venture relationships some networking
amazing um and
if you're
further in your career though and you
already have the influence and you even
have some income then you can be a
little bit more selective
awakening mission where you come to
toronto at some point
i mean i think definitely at some point
i mean i want to meet up with drake uh
as well as steph our editor who lives in
toronto um
and so i don't know when but we'll see
when drake texts me and invites me uh
dawn are you using a streaming app right
now like obs how you changing screens so
easily
i'm using stream yard and it's super
easy and so i'll throw a link for you
stream yard um do a video to just show
you how to use it so
uh how do you stream yard on youtube
step by step this video right here is
really cool it kind of explains
um
you know
the back end of it and everything
youtube channel i'll link to that right
now do this
uh destinations
on facebook and also youtube channel and
then click your youtube channel and
connect your podcast channel where
you're watching this live on youtube
uh highly recommend zoom yard this is
dead simple for me to run my own show
just like i'm doing right now
claire says any tips to prepare to
interview someone for your podcast live
streams any books you'd recommend for
this
uh hit like if you're getting value
today i love interviewing people i think
it's one of the best ways to get access
to high-level people you know on video
influencers we had garyvee and casey
neistat on and grant cardone on and some
big youtubers because we had an
interview show
and so helps you kind of build your
network um i've heard that tom bilyeu
spends 10 hours preparing for his
interviews on impact theory
so
i'm not saying that we all have that
time i don't spend that long necessarily
although oftentimes if i do read an
interview if i interview somebody i will
read their entire book which gives you
an entire it gives you an edge because
you know a lot you can highlight pages
you can be really informed
um but i think it just speaks to the
power of preparing period so how do you
prepare prepare like research them watch
their videos watch some of their other
interviews to maybe try to bring
something fresh to the conversation
um
i think that
what i would recommend is let me tell
you i think the biggest mistakes claire
that people make
a lot of interviewers are insecure and
they try to push themselves into the
interview too much so i've been
complimented they say sean you're a good
interviewer um and and one of the
reasons why is i don't try to i let them
shine
i just frame questions and listen
i dip right to the next question
i see
a lot of interviewers they it's like
they want to get their somebody will
make a point and they'll just echo it
they'll be like oh yeah that is so good
man that is true and what i've noticed
now of course conversationally there's
times to do that but your goal as an
interviewer is to
fight for the viewer
not fight to get your moment you'll look
better in the eyes of the listener if
they go dang
that person just you pulled value here's
your goal
pull value out of the guest
but here's who it's for
for the the audience
so if the guest says something and you
understand your audience so this is what
i think about on the think media podcast
i go okay i think about people on the
think media podcast
they want to learn about youtube so i
need to
tie this back into how it would would
help on youtube but also where are they
in their careers did was did the guest
potentially share something that would
need further clarity in that case
the key is this i'm fighting for the the
listener and if you become obsessed
that's the reason you research and get
to know the person you do want them to
feel honored but you know who matters
more than the guest
the viewer the listener
like when you become obsessed
with with the user experience
and that they would say that's a great
interviewer by the way
the the guest on the show will probably
be pumped as well and and the biggest
mistake i see people make
is
adding unnecessary
commentary to the conversation
whether they're insecure or not it
usually comes out of nervousness um and
so sometimes you know i also i will
pre-pla like for our interviews we just
did at social media marketing world pat
flynn's an example
the pre-interview michael stelzner does
the same thing michael stevensner has a
great podcast the social media examiner
podcast
he does a pre-call
and actually kind of you might not
necessarily be able to do this with
everybody but he kind of like
dials it in ahead of time and then the
final product's crazy why preparation
and in the pre-call
he
he goes i don't want you to really
unpack it but what would you say sean he
just did one with me
are like
the three biggest mistakes people make
with youtube okay cool and then he's
like now what's something you think
would add value and i pitch it a little
bit and he's like all right let's refine
it oh i don't even know if we could
cover these four things let's focus on
this thing and we spent about 30 minutes
crafting
the interview we're about to do and we
didn't get into all the weeds but we
kind of created an outline together
so i think that can uh help as as well
and there isn't necessarily
i think they're
you know
study the great interviewers like larry
king
um
you know what can you learn from some of
the 60 minutes interviewers oprah
interviewers you know some of the greats
but
i think if you also take people on a
journey
through it all and if you know coming up
your preparation of questions ahead of
time your understanding of the
guess that's coming on ahead of time
uh your understanding of your audience
uh and and then finally claire this is
all pretty intense i've been doing this
for a while
is just do it a lot like i was just
studying an interview that i did or just
watching an interview that's years old
and and after everything the person said
i go
powerful
so by the time the interview is over i
said powerful like 23 times so then so
watch your game tape
that would be the tip
do it a lot
no one's great right when they start
listen or watch the game tape
just like
maybe reston power kobe bryant was
famous for watching his game tape even
after he won how could i get better he
would go back and look at the game tape
so listen to it and then be like oh crap
i'm nervous i'll after everything they
say i go powerful
they make another point and i'd be like
wow that was so powerful and then i make
another point i'm like geez
powerful so then i started thinking okay
i need a few other things to say
sometimes i say nothing they they make
the point and then i go
to follow up with that and i and and so
the only way i've really crafted and
up up leveled my interview game
is by doing it a ton and also watching
my game tape while also studying you
know other great interviewers um and
then finally just being absolutely
obsessed with the listener and the
viewer and not trying to like even get
my two cents in unless it truly adds
value to the viewer
and not just you know me trying to
shine on the whatever oh i gotta
i gotta block a user
i gotta block this adult dating site
that's spamming up our comments
um and so
uh
the viewer experience is everything
yep do you think about the
viewer
first or don't you
good gary v said once
do we have that clip
you want you want a little garyvee
refresh by the way gary vaynerchuk
speaking at at uh
growth video live right and so check
this out are you putting out
entertainment or are you putting out
education because 90 of people are
putting out selfish content what was
your question completely starting from
zero uh versus somebody that has
resources or team or already started
building an influence you know it's kind
of one in the same like it's kind of
like back to something we talked about
before which is like making the best
thing for the end audience i have
synthesized my thoughts into
entertainment and education that has
become very clear to me that either
you're doing entertainment or you're
doing education and i actually do think
that
certain people like myself when you're
doing entertainment and education you
can really get crazy um but that's what
i would say i would say to somebody with
resources a four-person team like look
forget about everything else because
look i did all i did all my content by
myself for seven years people forget
that like oh easy for you to say i'm
like
i'm like you're not you know it's that
iceberg yeah i'm like you see me i'm
like you know i'm like you see me now
i think it's about are you putting out
entertainment are you putting out
education because 90 of people are
putting out selfish content
yeah 90 of people are putting out press
releases
they want to they want you to think
something about them they're making it
selfish for themselves they wanted to go
to maui
and serve so that's the content you're
getting but did that bring you any value
they want you to think they're cool 90
of the content right now
are people acting like pr agents of
themselves i'm asking people to look
like educators or entertainers
do you think about the audience first
or don't you
do you think about the audience first or
don't you
that's the game right there man thank
you gary vaynerchuk
for the tip when you of course
what is your passion of course
what is your dream i just want to be a
famous influencer i'm just trying to
build up and make money man hey click
subscribe click like my name's sean
click like hey
subscribe to me me
this is all about me my channel is about
me listening about me you want to hear
my story it's all about me that's what
everyone's doing
now listen
you matter friend
and i know you want to use youtube to
accomplish your dreams and goals but
that's i think such an unlock of when
you put the audience
first
when you put the viewer first by the way
that's the interviewer's mistake when
interviewers
are trying to get themselves to shine as
opposed to making the guest shine and
then even better
having the viewer say that was amazing
and i got value and so gary really
influenced me with that i'm so glad he's
speaking at our event grow a video live
2022
and so uh i'm excited to learn the
latest and the greatest from gary and
today's growth video live show of course
is brought to you by growth video live
early bird pricing is ending at midnight
tonight and so of course you can get
tickets after we're about 60 full on
tickets for the event in person um and
so don't sleep get your ticket and you
can get an extra five percent off
discount
with the promo code gwvl show
at
growwithvideolive.com
fired up to have gary vaynerchuk with us
in person live
and uh grateful for his influence in my
life over
the years
them tube that's right we think it's
youtube it's your tube bro and it is
videos about me
i'm so pretty
i'm so pretty
i'm so pretty and nitty in me what is
that what song is that man
and and i get it because there's some
people
that are succeeding
when it's all about them youtube me tube
but uh but yeah when you really think
about the viewer first things get
interesting because you're you're just
thinking about what they'll love what
they'll want to watch why they click
away what will add value to them what
their problems are what their ambitions
are
um and so uh
yes okay friends listen
so many great questions coming in we've
been here for two hours and 41 minutes
super stream on a saturday i wanted to
really make sure that you got this
information uh specifically just because
again ticket prices are going up and if
you don't come to grow a video live cool
but if you do
now's the best time to get a ticket
because may 1st prices go up so
grow a videolive.com definitely use the
show code to save more
smash like if you got value out of
today's stream excited to hang out with
you check out the replay a lot of
valuable content was uh shared hopefully
let me know your aha moment as we always
do if you're here live 123 of us
um
hit me up in the chat hit me up in the
comments
it's time to get to the most important
part of the show
and it's action taker time hashtag
action taker
hashtag i'm an action taker
listen i don't care what you learned
today
i should probably eat i'm in hangry mode
oh my brain was tickled because shawn
shared such a cool insight cool bro what
are you gonna do with it
oh my gosh did you see that one thing
that he shared that was such a powerful
insight i just learned something well
cool it's cool you learned something i'm
all for it but when are you gonna do
something
so here's the question what is your
action item what are you gonna do next
randy
drop the time to stop consuming and
start creating
what is your next action
so drop it are you dropping are you
shooting a video are you researching a
video are you registering for grow a
video live so that you can network and
get in the room with other uh
video creators that are going to help
you level
up
are you going to
go
um schedule out your may
how about that april 30th
how about you plan your next month prior
planning prevents poor performance how
about you look ahead over the next 30
days and say okay in may this is what
i'm gonna shoot okay these are the
videos i'm gonna shoot here's the block
of time on my google calendar sean i
don't even know how to use google
calendar i'm just kind of like a
creative spirit you're so constricting
when you told me to start using google
calendar
you know what you need to start getting
some order in your life
you need to order that creativity
because i i respect your creative spirit
but you need some creative discipline to
help you actually get some stuff done
hashtag action takers
plan out your may friend plan out when
you're going to shoot when you're going
to edit when you're going to upload
do some research answerthepublic.com
get into your video ranking academy
modules for those of us that are in vra
plan out when you're going to learn more
plan out when you're going to do more
what's the next video you're shooting
awakening missions ready to hustle 100
videos in the next 90 days you know one
of the themes we saw today
we saw someone asking about strategy who
hadn't uploaded in a year and we saw
someone who has been uploading like
crazy in a year and guess who was
getting the results
my mind was blown
oh my gosh
you actually get better results on
youtube
when you upload videos to youtube
stop the presses
open the stock exchange
tweet on
send a tweet elon
the news is out
i can do better on youtube if i upload
videos on youtube
that's right come on tube data workshop
33 videos this year and 16 videos
planned already that's what i'm talking
about
action takers out here
and so
we got cj always keeping a list and
always planning i like it cj prior
planning helps
prevent poor performance if you fail to
plan you plan to fail learning how to
color grade let's freaking go i'm going
to bat shoot some videos and upload them
before grow a video live gene jordan in
the house crushing brian gilman i'm
writing a script for my next video
because we are action takers
action takers
sean this is
this is condescending no it's not i'm
this is your coach
this is friday night lights on a
saturday
saying put the reps in press record
punch fear in the face and crush your
excuses plan your may
yeah and join us in las vegas at
growethvideolive.com gamingmom
mum 50 videos planned to and editing
let's keep them coming man
keep the videos coming out creator
people i have a content calendar google
sheet with every platform and every day
of the year
so i'm talking about organized
systems
we don't rise to the level of our goals
we fall to the level of our systems come
on google sheets come on google calendar
come on the brazil show two videos to
publish this week and planning the next
shoot
i love it man
listen i respect you i'm grateful for
you being here thanks for hanging out on
a saturday smash like if you got value
it's time to take action it's time to go
press record i will see you on the think
media podcast this tuesday i will see
you in las vegas or online for growth
video live i will see you in the next
think media video and until then keep
crushing it keep smashing it and we will